hey everyone welcome to simply learns
youtube channel in this session we will
be learning who is a business analyst
and business analytics with excel but
before we begin i would like to take a
quick confirmation from our viewers if
the screen is clearly visible and the
audio is clear if yes kindly type yes in
the chat section and if there is
anything that we can improvise then do
let us know in the chat section
great i can see a lot of positive
responses from our viewers thank you i
think it's clear that we can get started
now before we begin i would like to tell
you guys that we have daily updates on
multiple technologies so if you're a
tech geek in a continuous hunt for
latest technological trends then
consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that bell icon to never miss an update
from simplylearn
now without further ado let's get
started with the agenda for today's
discussion
we will get started by understanding the
need for business analyst and how
important is for a company to have a
business analyst on board now followed
by that we will understand the critical
skills and roles and responsibilities of
a business analyst followed by that we
will understand the key knowledge areas
of a business analyst later we will
understand business analytics with excel
then we will differentiate the two
different key terms that are the
business analyst and data analyst
so as discussed before we will dive a
little deep into business analysis with
excel where we will get started with the
basic fundamentals of excel then we will
get started with the lookup functions
which are the hlookup vlookup and x
lookup in excel and we will also
understand the fundamental functions
which are used in day-to-day business
analytics followed by that we will learn
sorting and filtering in excel then we
will have conditional formatting data
validation and the most important part
which is the pivot tables and favorite
charts in excel and finally we will
understand data analysis with toolpak so
with that we have finished the agenda i
hope i made myself clear with the agenda
now we can get started with our first
topic that is the importance of business
analyst
or to our training experts
we will understand the importance of
business analyst with a sort and
interesting story
so meet rob he runs a cafe in a small
town far away his cafe is one of the
oldest and most popular eateries in town
rob's cafe was hugely popular amongst
customers and it was doing very well
until the onset of the deadly
coronavirus
due to kovite 19 like other eateries rob
was forced to shut down his cafe too
this took a heavy toll on his business
and subsequently he lost his customers
none of his customers visited his cafe
and this resulted in a huge loss for him
he knew he couldn't afford to close his
business forever as it would take time
for coronavirus to be eradicated
but he was lost this situation was new
to him and he didn't know how to reopen
his business amidst this pandemic
after a lot of brainstorming he
recollected reading about business
analysts
he remembered that business analysts are
professionals who enable a change in an
organization he felt like a business
analyst could help him sort out his
current business problems hence
without wasting any time he set out to
hire a business analyst
he hired ted the business analyst to
help him with his ongoing business
problems
rob entrusted ted with reopening the
business
the first step ted took was to have a
discussion with rob and understand the
business problems and the objectives
that is ideally the first step a
business analyst would take
on discussion with rob ted learned that
the business objective was to reopen the
business and get at least 80 percent of
the customer base back in addition to
that rob also wanted ted to look for
sustainable ways to reopen and continue
the business in the long run amidst the
pandemic
ted studied the case
and he came up with a few suggestions
that he thought was fit for rob's
business
his first suggestion was to develop an
exclusive home delivery app for rob's
cafe
this way ted knew that business will
improve as customers prefer home
delivery in the current scenario
next ted suggested that rob has work
from home meal boxes added to his menu
many professionals are working from home
currently and having work from home meal
boxes would be a good pick for such
professionals in the middle of a busy
day
ted's third suggestion was to bring down
the selling cost by providing discount
coupons that can be utilized by
customers
having a discount will enable more
customers to order from rob's cafe of
course it was not possible to get the
customer base back without any short of
price cuts in the current situation
finally ted suggested the drop staff
would facilitate home delivery orders
this way he didn't have to lay off his
staff and at the same time get the home
delivery running so these were a few
suggestions given by ted yes depending
on the situation business analysts can
take up different approaches
so after the suggestions were accepted
by rob for the app ted began to make
sure that the development went well by
collaborating with the it team
that became the intermediary between the
iit team and rob he provided suggestions
to the team checked the app through user
interface testing and made sure that the
requirements met well
the same applied to the other business
requirements and changes as well ted
held regular meetings to gaze the
progress and also kept robb in the loop
and updated him with the status of the
project
attending regular catch-ups helped rob
gain an insight into the progress and
give his feedback from time to time
ted made sure that the entire case was
well documented by doing so he could
always refer to the documents in the
future with similar cases as well
ted
made presentations that showed rob the
business growth after implementing the
changes and ted always supported his
presentations with data
rob was very impressed with ted's
business approach
such an approach not only helped rob
reopen his business amidst the cove at
19 but also helped him get 80 of his
customer base back ted successfully
brought about a positive change in rob's
business which was highly beneficial
so that is how ted the business analyst
helped rob make a business sustainable
this was the importance of having a
business analyst in rob's organization
don't you think every organization
should have a business analyst
well yes depending on the business
domain and the situation the roles and
responsibilities may vary let's start
off and have a look at a day in the life
of a business analyst through a small
story so meet angela who is working as a
business analyst in an application
development firm
her firm builds applications for clients
depending on their requirements our next
character is rob he is a budding
entrepreneur with a vision of setting up
his own e-commerce app he plans on
selling several electronic gadgets like
phones laptops cameras etc on his app
so what is rob's first step well he
approaches angela's firm one day with
the vision of creating his ecommerce app
angela and rob start talking business
and angela promises to help rob with his
app creation she assures him that she
will look into his business requirements
and coordinate with him to get the app
running
rob is happy about it and increased to
cooperate with angela regarding all the
business requirements from his end
angela as we know is the business
analyst she starts planning rob's
project and without any delay she
embarks on this project's journey she
has a set of planned steps that will
help her fulfill rob's requirements
but what are the steps she takes is her
approach going to be effective and quick
let's find out the answers to these
questions now up next you can learn
about angela's approach that helps her
deliver rob's project smoothly and
without any hassles
these steps that we are going to look at
are the typical roles and
responsibilities of a business analyst
here we will understand these roles
better with respect to angela's and drop
story first and foremost angela
understands rob's business objectives
problems and requirements
without understanding this do you think
angela will be able to proceed no hence
a business analyst like angela
understands the problems related to
rob's business and comes up with the
right solution to achieve the goals of
the business she brainstorms around what
is best suited for an e-commerce app
focusing on electronic gadgets in the
next step angela gathers all the
necessary requirements
here she understands rob's requirements
and makes sure that they are on the same
page regarding the project and its goals
both of them together arrive at a
stipulator deadline for the project
completion
she gathers relevant information based
on security of the app the payment setup
based to login cost of the products and
style to name a few
once angela has an in-depth
understanding of rob's project and
gathers all the necessary requirements
she starts allocating resources by
keeping in mind the budget of the
project
here she recognizes and allocates tasks
and resources to the development team
pas work closely with the development
team to design the solution for a
problem
angela ensures that the development team
doesn't spend their time understanding
rob's requirements
in this step along with the development
team she finalizes the software and
tools required to build the project
angela doesn't rest until the project is
delivered to rob she continuously
monitors the progress and constantly
provides her feedback to the development
team with respect to the app's layout
design and other features she gives them
suggestions in order to improve the
application in the next step angela
collects feedback of the prototype
version of the app from the users
she notes down if the prototype is fine
or if it requires more work pas validate
if the project is running fine with the
help of use acceptance testing they
verify if the solution being worked on
is in line with the requirements and
ensure that the final product satisfies
the use expectations
bas also assess the functional and
non-functional requirements after
collecting feedback angela moves to one
of her most crucial duties and that is
building reports data visualization is a
key skill for any ba
in order to gauge the performance of the
app and get valuable insights from it
angela builds reports using various data
visualization tools like tableau power
bi and quick view reports can be general
reports such as detailed reports or it
can be dashboard reports such as
visualized reports with
multi-dimensional analysis based on
display of business indicators it is not
uncommon for issues to crop up amidst
this entire process
hence angela conducts regular meetings
with the development team and rob to
solve problems quickly
having these meetings will help rob
understand the status of the project and
it will also help the teams proceed in
the right path throughout this project
phase angela makes sure to maintain
transparency on completion of the
project angela documents and presents
the project findings to rob generally
business analysts present the project
outcomes to the stakeholders and clients
along with maintenance reports angela
notes on all the project learnings and
details in a concise manner this will
help her take better decisions in the
future and these documents will save her
time while implementing the next project
now that she has completed all her
duties and responsibilities with respect
to rob's project she is ready to deliver
the final e-commerce application to rob
for use rob is rest assured that the
application developed by angela's firm
is apt for his business and just what he
wanted
angela's streamlined approach made it
easier for the project to be delivered
within the stipulated time period rob is
happy and i'm sure he will come back to
angela's firm for projects in the future
so those responsibilities that we saw
angela carry out are ideally the roles
and responsibilities for any business
analyst out there
yes some may vary depending on the
company you work for and the project
you're working on if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
business analyst is a professional who
is responsible for bridging the gap
between it and business teams
they use analytics to evaluate processes
determine requirements deliver
data-driven solutions and generate
reports to executives and stakeholders
business analyst is an individual who is
a part of the business operation and
works closely with the technology team
to improve the quality of the services
being delivered they also help in
assisting in integration and testing of
new solutions
growing a career in a field with high
demand such as business analysis could
be a challenge and competition for
business analyst positions can be
intense
so you should have a clear understanding
of the roles and responsibilities of a
business analyst
a ba should successfully identify and
recognize the organization's business
objective they should understand the
business problems and think of a
lucrative business solution
need to understand and collect the
business requirements from clients and
stakeholders allocate the right
resources and improve the existing
business
documentation of business findings is
another important key role of a business
analyst
bas interact with the development team
to design the solution for solving a
particular problem
they often need to spend a certain
amount of time in meetings in order to
save the development team from spending
their time and understanding the
stakeholders requirement
they often give feedback on the layout
of a software application as to what all
features need to be added and what
functionalities should the application
contain and also implement the newly
designed features that a business needs
while bas identify the needs define the
features write use cases uncover
business rules and manage issues they
should also gauge the functional and
non-functional requirements in a
business
business analysts run meeting with
stakeholders and other authorities hence
discussing issues with the client
face-to-face can do wonders and even
help in solving problems quickly they
engage with business leaders and users
to understand how data driven changes to
products services software and hardware
can improve efficiency and add value
they verify and validate if the project
is running well with the help of user
acceptance testing and the solutions are
in line with the client's requirements
they also ensure that the product
delivered satisfies the user
requirements
finally bas write documentations and
build visualizations to explain all the
findings and draw business insights
they also deliver maintenance reports
they need to develop informative
coherent and usable documents for the
success of a project
business analyst skills are a
combination of technical as well as
non-technical skills often referred to
as soft skills
the skills for a business analyst are
not only acquired through training but
through experience and combined with the
ability to understand situations and the
motive behind the problem so let's have
a look at the top skills to become a
successful business analyst
the first skill we have is understanding
the business objective
for a business analyst it is important
to know the goals and objectives of the
business it is advised that business
analysts should have a good knowledge of
the business operations in his or her
organization
a business analyst should understand the
problems related to the business and
come up with the right solution business
analysts will resolve the problems that
have been identified and not avoid them
they work on individual actions and
tasks that will build towards the
achievement of the goals of the business
objectives of the business can be to
expand customer base in order to
increase sales scale up production so
that it is in line with the revenue
growth improve revenue streams through
increasing perceived product value or
increasing marketing budget according to
the revenue
business analysts would have the natural
curiosity and determination to continue
learning and figuring out how things fit
together
even as business analysts become
managers it is important to stay in
touch with the industry and its changes
the next important skill a business
analyst should have is analytical and
critical thinking
now there is a famous quote by thomas
elva edition which says
five percent of the people think
10 percent of the people think they
think and the other 85 percent would
rather die than think
business analysts are paid to think
a business analyst would be able to
analyze and interpret the client's
requirements clearly
business analysts required good focus in
order to collect and understand the
needs of the client
critical thinking involves evaluating
several options before arriving at the
desired solution
in certain situations a stakeholder may
give a requirement that's not
necessarily tied up to any business
value but rather to their own increased
convenience applying critical thinking
demands not taking all the statements of
the stakeholders for granted critical
thinking allows the business analyst to
distinguish between requirements that
add value to the business and those
that should be given a low priority a
business analyst must be creative in
order to reach stated goals but
resources are limited and the conditions
are non-ideal
the third important skill for a business
analyst is communication and
interpersonal skills
understanding and being properly
understood is key to any profession
if you are unable to clearly specify and
communicate requirements to any
stakeholder then you may not fully
understand the requirements yourself
being a business analyst is like being
multilingual
you have to speak several different
languages while conveying the same
message
business analysts apply communication
skills at every point they use
communication and interpersonal skills
when the project is launched while
gathering requirements when
collaborating with stakeholders and also
while validating the final solution
listening reading and writing skills are
very critical for a business analyst
this would be capable of facilitating
meetings
business analysts use verbal and written
communication to convey ideas concepts
facts and opinions to a variety of
stakeholders
non-verbal communication skills enable
the effective sending and receiving of
messages but not limited to body
movement posture facial expressions
gestures and eye contact
effective listening allows the business
analyst to accurately understand
information that has been communicated
verbally
fourth in our list of skills we have
negotiation and cost benefit analysis
being a successful business analyst
requires working with and interacting
with many people
these people include clients business
leaders project team members project
stakeholders
vendors private sector representatives
industry leaders and so forth
business analysts negotiate at every
turn during the course of a project
at the initial stage of a project
negotiation skills are used to determine
what should be included in the vision of
the project
as details emerge negotiation skills are
used by all parties involved to
determine which requests become
requirements and which requirements have
higher priority
as the project progresses negotiation
skills help to determine the functional
design which fulfill the requirements
technical decisions also require
negotiation skills
business analysts also perform cost
benefit analysis to conduct an
assessment of the benefits and costs
anticipated in a project when
organizations undertake new projects it
is advisable for business analysts that
they use cost benefit analysis to
establish whether such projects should
be embarked or not
business analysts should be able to
achieve a profitable outcome for your
company while finding a solution for the
client that makes them happy
this balancing act demands the ability
to influence a mutual solution and
maintain professional relationship
up next we have our fifth skill that is
decision making
the quality of decisions made by
business analyst is what matters a lot
because it has a direct impact on the
company's business
thus it is important for every business
analyst to think from all aspects before
presenting the decision or strategy
they must be having good problem solving
skills as well
business analysts should have a knack to
think out of the box and find a solution
to problems majorly a business analyst
follows five major steps while making a
decision
these steps are define the problem
find and define the alternative
approaches
evaluate the alternative approaches
make the decision based on these
approaches and test
and finally implement the solution
while some may argue that the technical
team is responsible for designing the
solution the business analyst still
remains instrumental in ensuring that
the design conforms to the requirements
that have been approved
now that we have reached half way
through the skills i would like to ask
all our viewers to please subscribe to
our channel and hit the bell icon to
never miss an update from simply learn
moving on
we have another really important
business analyst skill that is
idea about programming languages
business analysts would have a good
hands-on programming knowledge for
performing better and faster analysis of
data knowledge of r and python is highly
beneficial
business analysts can help solve complex
problems by writing efficient codes
both r and python have a vast collection
of libraries and packages for data
manipulation data wrangling data
visualization and data analytics
some of these libraries are numpy pandas
deep flyer tidier ggplot and matplotlib
in addition to these it is good to
understand statistical software like sas
and spss using these programming
languages such as python r and sas you
can analyze and visualize large datasets
as well as create machine learning
models for making future business
predictions
the seventh skill in our list is
creation of reports and dashboards
a business analyst should be proficient
in using various business intelligence
tools for creating reports and
dashboards
reports created by business analysts can
be general reports such as detail report
grouped report cross tab report column
report query report data entry report
etc or it can be dashboard reports such
as visualize report with
multi-dimensional analysis based on
display of business indicators
dashboard reports are developed by
business analyst to solve business
decision making problems different from
the tabular interface of the general
report the dashboard report adopts the
canvas like operation interface
knowledge of tableau power bi and click
view are required to make different
types of reports depending on the
business requirements
now the eighth skill in our list of
skills is database and sql
business analysts often work with data
that is structured in nature hence to
store and process this data they should
have knowledge of relational databases
such as microsoft sql server oracle
database mysql database as well as nosql
databases
also having hands-on experience with sql
is a must for a business analyst to
access retrieve manipulate and analyze
data so they should be able to write
data definition and data manipulation
commands such as create update delete
and insert
microsoft excel is the ninth skill in
our list
excel is one of the oldest and most
popular and powerful analytics and
reporting tool used in the industries
for working with data
business analysts use excel to perform
various calculations budget analysis and
data analysis to derive meaningful
insights and take decisions
they sort filter and create pivot tables
to summarize the data
business analysts can also create
different charts and graphs using excel
to generate dynamic reports related to a
business problem
business analysts can use excel to
create revenue growth models for new
products based on new customer forecasts
when planning an editorial calendar for
a website business analysts can list out
dates and topics in a spreadsheet
when creating a budget for a small
product they can list expense categories
in a spreadsheet update it monthly and
create a chart to show how close the
product is to budget across each
category
business analyst can calculate customer
discounts based on monthly purchase
volume by product
they can even summarize customer revenue
by product to find areas where to build
strong customer relationships
and finally in the list of skills we
have documentation and presentation
you could have all the industry
experience in the world but if it's
paired with poor business analyst
practices you could be more of a risk to
the organization than a business analyst
with no industry experience at all
a business analyst must be able to
document their project learnings and
results in a concise and compact form
they should also be confident about
presenting their findings and
conclusions in front of the stakeholders
and clients
organized documentation will help you
communicate technical concepts to
non-technical employees it is important
that a business analyst notes down all
the details that they learn from their
projects
this will help them take better
decisions in the future also if similar
problems arise at a later stage they can
implement the same solution thereby
saving a lot of time and unwanted
problems
while business analysts are generally
not responsible for making decisions
regarding project solutions
decision making skills are still
important for understanding gathering
and presenting relevant information to
assess decision makers with selecting
the optimal solution
with that we have covered our top skills
for a business analyst if you have any
questions related to the skills that we
covered then please put it in the chat
section our team will help you solve
your queries
now
let me tell you how simply learn can
help you grow your career in business
analytics and help you become a business
analyst
so let me search for simply learn here
this is the simply learn website
and
on the search bar let me look for
business
analyst
you can see
there are a few courses related to
business analyst so let me open these
two courses
so let's go to the first course
so this is the business analyst masters
program
now
this program is endorsed
education provider is iiba
now if you look on the right we have the
different courses that will be covered
as part of this master's program
so there is introduction to business
analysis
certified business analytics
professional will also learn about
agilent scrum
there's business analytics with excel
we'll also get training in sql there's
tableau training
and you will also get to work on
business analyst caption projects
if i scroll down
now here are the tools that will be
covered as part of this course so
there's microsoft excel zera tableau
power bi postgres sql
then this plan box target process
and others
here you can see the
program advisors
and if i scroll further
is the entire course content we have
these are the different courses
that you will be learning in this course
and
after you finish the course you will
receive a certificate which will look
similar to
this so please go ahead and enroll to
this course if you want to start your
career
in business analytics now let me take
you to another program
we have post graduate program in
business analysis
now this is in
partnership with purdue university and
endorsed education provider is iipa
if i scroll down you can see here the
key features of this course
you'll get
purdue postgraduate program
certification alumni association
membership
master classes from purdue faculties
enrollment in simply learns job assist
there's 170 plus hours of blended
learning 11 plus hands-on projects
custom projects in three domains
if i scroll further
on the right you can see this is the
purdue certification that you will
receive after finishing the course
and you will also get
the certificate received by
international institute of business
analysis that is iiba
let's scroll down
you also have the advantage for
enrolling to simply learn job assist
program so you will get im jobs pro
membership for six months
resume assistance and career monitoring
you'll also have interview preparation
and career affairs
now here you can see the program details
so
you will learn about an introduction to
business analysis certified business
analysis professional
there's a island scrum
business analytics with excel tableau
training business analyst capstone
project
and you also have the opportunity to
enroll for some electives so we have
purdue university business analysis
master class
you can also enroll to a power bi course
and there is agilent scrum foundation
if i scroll down
here you can see the skills that will be
covered as part of this program so
this business analysis
there's alicitation and collaboration
requirement analysis planning and
monitoring
let me click on view more you have
strategy analysis dashboarding
wireframing that's data visualization
statistical analysis using excel sql
database
there's requirement life cycle
management and lots more
so these are the tools that will be
covered in this course we have microsoft
excel zera fog buzz
plan box that's rally power bi pro
square sql
that's version one target process and
others
and now this is the important part
though these are the industrially
related projects that you will get to
work on once you enroll to this course
so the first project is canteen ordering
system for unilever
we also have library management system
for stanford university
there's whatsapp pay and you can see the
description of these projects
mentioned below
and
you also have
hospital management system for myoclinic
there are our course advisors for this
course now they are directly related to
purdue university
if we scroll further this is the
learner's profile and how the industry
trend has been for business analysts
so please go ahead and enroll to this
program if you
really want to start your career or you
want to grow your career as a business
analyst
now here is a quick roadmap that depicts
what a fresher needs to possess to
become a business analyst
first they need to have a graduation
degree in a related field
then
knowledge of sql and relational database
is very important
thirdly a fresher should have good
hands-on experience with programming
languages and that's a prerequisite
and finally they need to have good
communication skills to nail the role of
a business analyst
up next we have the roadmap that depicts
what an experienced professional needs
to process to become a business analyst
firstly they should have good knowledge
of the domain they are currently working
in
next they should know how to write sql
queries
an experienced professional should be
good with programming languages
in addition to that they need to have
good communication and negotiation
skills
finally they should be good at creating
interactive reports using business
intelligence tools
in addition to that having a
certification offered by international
institute of business analysis such as
certified business analysis professional
would be highly beneficial
let's now learn the business analysis
knowledge areas
first up
we have business analysis planning and
monitoring
now this knowledge area describes the
tasks used to organize and coordinate
business analysis efforts
it involves planning business analysis
approach stakeholder engagement business
analysis governance as well as
information management
then we have illustration and
collaboration
now this knowledge area describes the
tasks used to prepare and conduct
elicitation activities and confirm the
results
it also includes communicating business
analysis information and stakeholder
engagement
the third knowledge area we have is
requirements lifecycle management
so this knowledge area describes the
tasks that we perform in order to manage
and maintain requirements throughout
their lifecycle it covers the creation
changes privatization traceability and
governance processes
fourth in our list we have strategy
analysis
now this knowledge area describes the
tasks used to identify the business need
address that need and align the change
strategy within the enterprise
you need to analyze the current state
define the future state assess risk and
define change strategy
then we have requirements analysis and
design definition this knowledge area
describes the tasks used to organize
requirements specify and model
requirements it also validates and
verifies information and identifies
solution options the final knowledge
area we have is solution evaluation this
knowledge area measures the solution
performance analyzes performance
measures
assess solution limitations and
recommends actions to increase solution
value now let's discuss two of the most
widely used methodologies in any
business analysis process
these methods are popularly used in the
industries to ensure smooth running of
projects
the first methodology we are going to
talk about is the agile methodology
agile is an incremental and iterative
approach to project management and
software development it helps team
deliver value to their customers faster
and with fewer obstacles
teams can manage a project by breaking
it up into several stages and involving
constant collaboration with stakeholders
along with continuous improvement and
iteration at every stage
so the steps involved in an agile
project development includes
planning the project in terms of
business goals budget time duration for
completing the project and resource
needed
then we have designing the solution for
the problem at hand
the third step is developing the
solution this could be a software a
website an application etc
it's done by the development team
next we have testing the product in the
next step of the life cycle
deploying the developed product to check
if it's working fine and finally we have
reviewing the product and getting
feedback from customers clients
stakeholders etc now in agile
methodology the entire work is broken
down into several sprints
after each sprint
we get a shippable product and that
product is reviewed by the client or the
stakeholder
the suggestions are incorporated in the
next sprint
here you can see we have sprint 1 sprint
2 and sprint 3 and all of them have the
6 steps that we discussed in the agile
methodology process now let's discuss
this scrum methodology
scrum is a subset of the agile framework
it is one of the most widely used
lightweight process frameworks for agile
development
you can easily collaborate develop and
deliver complex products of the highest
possible value
scrum empowers the development team and
supports working in small teams like 8
to 10 members scrum significantly
increases productivity and reduces time
this process enables organizations to
adjust smoothly to rapidly changing
requirements and produce a product that
meets evolving business goals
okay so the concepts and practices in
scrum can be divided into three
categories
first we have three roles
a product owner owns the product backlog
and writes user stories and acceptance
criteria
they are responsible for privatizing the
product backlog and deciding the release
date and the content a product owner is
the one who is responsible for the
return on investment or roi of the
product a scrum master is a servant who
encourages and demands self-organization
from the development team they enable
close cooperation across all roles and
functions addresses resource issues and
disobedience of scrum practices a
development team comprises individuals
working together to develop and deliver
the requested and committed product
agreements the development team builds
the product and includes all the
expertise necessary to deliver the
potential shippable product each sprint
the second category comprises of three
artifacts the product backlog is an
ordered list of the features and
requirements needed to complete the
project the list can include bugs or
defects that need to be resolved
features that must be added another
technical or project work your team has
to complete before the project is over
the sprint backlog includes only what
needs to be completed during the current
sprint
it often has greater detail and more
complete user stories than the rest of
the product backlog
once created no one can add to the
sprint backlog except the development
team the product increment is the
version of the product that will be
delivered at the end of each sprint
while the sprint backlog outlines what
must be completed within a sprint the
product increment details the outcome of
all that work
the increment is a prototype or working
version of the final product expected by
the customer
the final category we have is sprint
ceremonies
there are four ceremonies in total
in sprint planning the team
meets and decides what they need to
complete in the coming sprint
sprint review is a type of meeting in
which the team demonstrates what they
shipped in the sprint
in the sprint retrospective the team
reviews their work identifying what they
did well and what didn't go as planned
so that they can make the next print
better
daily scrum is a stand-up meeting or a
very short like 15 to 20 minutes meeting
for the team to make sure that they are
all on the same page
now
let's talk about the average annual
salary of a business analyst
according to pay scale the average
annual salary of a business analyst in
the united states is sixty eight
thousand nine hundred and seventy three
dollars
while in india a business analyst can
earn nearly six lakh rupees per annum
now talking about the companies hiring
for business analysts we have the indian
e-commerce payment system and financial
technology company paytm
american mnc cognigent and british dutch
multinational oil and gas company shell
we also have cisco the search engine
giant google and dell
finally in our list of companies we have
einstein young global limited american
multinational computer technology
corporation oracle and british
multinational investment bank and
financial services company barclays
with that let's discuss the top business
analysis tools and software used by
business analysts
we have the widely used spreadsheet
application microsoft excel
web-based kanban style list making
application trello relational database
management systems such as mysql
microsoft sql server and postgresql
then we have bug tracking and agile
project management product zera and
tableau software for data visualization
okay so let's look at a demo on business
analyst training
often times business analysts work on
structured data using excel to prepare
reports and dashboards
they do create pivot tables and pivot
charts to summarize and analyze data
find trends and insights to make
critical decisions
so in this demo we will work on a sales
data set from the united states and
analyze the total revenue total profit
the quantity sold for different
categories and subcategories of products
across various regions segments cities
etc
now let me show you the data set first
okay so here is my data set you can see
there are
nearly
9994 rows and we have
17 columns
you can see this is a sales data set and
the first column is of order date then
we have the shipment date we have the
shipment mode next we have the customer
name
that is the customer who purchased the
product we have the segment the country
name there's only united states then we
have the different cities from the u.s
we have the state names
and if i go to the right you can see the
categories of product
we also have the sub categories
next we have the product name
then we have our sales value
now you can assume this to be in dollars
then we have the quantity that was sold
for each product then we have the
discount column and finally we have the
profit column
so let's analyze this data set using
different charts and graphs
first let's create a pivot table to see
the sales by region and year
so here we want to see the sales of all
the years in different regions of the
united states
so for that
i'll click on any cell inside this data
set
go to the insert tab
and here i have the option to create a
pivot table
i'll click on this create pivot table
option
and you can see it has selected my
entire data
and here i'll choose new worksheet that
is the place where i want to place this
pivot table
and let's click on ok
so you can see it has created a new
sheet which is sheet2
and
let's drag our columns
onto the different sections in this
pivot table fields
so since i want to know
the region
and the year so let's drag the order
date first
and
let's delete
the quarter column so i'll click on
remove field
i don't want this field so i have my
ears first
and then
let's drag
region column
under columns
and
we want to know the sales for
all the years in different regions so
i'll drag
sales onto values
you can see here we have our pivot table
ready if you want you can go ahead and
rename this row labels and column labels
now
with this table ready let's create a
line chart
this will
help you analyze your data better
so what you can do is
go to the insert tab and here
under recommended charts
you can go for line chart you can see
the line chart preview here
and click on ok
there you go
how easily excel has created a pivot
chart for us based on
this pivot table
now if you notice the lines in this
graph you can see the different regions
and here is the legend
now
if you see the yellow line which is
actually for the west region
so the sales had declined from 2014
to 2015
and then it gradually started increasing
from 2015 to 2017 onwards
and if you see the orange line or the
red line it is for the east region
the sales have been continuously
increasing you can see the trend here
similarly
if you see the central region
the sales generated was steady from 2014
till 2015
then it increased in 2016 and after 2016
it became constant
similarly you can analyze the south
region as well
now let's say you want to know the sales
by each category of product and the
different segments so you can do that as
well
let's go to our sheet one where we have
our data set
let me click on any cell i'll go to
insert
and i'll choose pivot table
here
let it be new worksheet i'll click on ok
all right so since we want to know the
sales value again so let's drag sales
onto
values field
and now
i'll choose
category
under rows
so
let's select category under rows
and then
we want to know
for each segment also
so what i can do is
i'll choose segment under columns
you can see i have my pivot table ready
so here you have
the furniture office supplies and
technology as the categories of products
and on the top you can see consumer
corporate home office has the different
segments
now let's create a
visual out of this pivot table so i'll
go to recommended charts
and
let's say this time i want to
create a bar chart now this is a
horizontal bar chart
let's click on ok
if i close this
and i bring it to here you can see this
is a nice bar chart
and below you can see the sales values
and on the y-axis you can see the
different categories of products and in
the legend we have the segments
now if you want you can edit this chart
as well
so let's delete
or hide all field buttons on the chart
all right
similarly let's do this for
our line chart as well let's hide these
field buttons
okay
all right
now
let's suppose you want to know which
segment made the highest and the lowest
profits
so for that you can create a pivot table
as well
so i'll click on any cell
go to the insert tab
and choose pivot table i click on ok
all right
now say we want to know the profit by
each segment
so i'll first choose profit on to values
and
let's drag
the segment column
on to rows so we have our pivot table
ready
now here if you want to know which
segment made the highest or the lowest
profit you can sort this data so click
on any cell under sum of profit
right click and here you have the short
option
so let's do
sort smallest to largest which is in
ascending order
okay so here you can see consumer
segment made the highest amount of
profit while the home office segment
made the lowest amount of profit now
based on this pivot table you can create
a pie chart
let's do that
i'll go to insert
and here under recommended charts
i'll select
pi and let's click on ok
there you go
we have a nice pie chart ready
now the gray color pi represents your
consumer segment which made the highest
amount of profit you can also validate
it from the pivot table
while the blue segment which is actually
home office made the lowest amount of
profit
now let's remove this field from here
i'll right click and select
hide all field buttons on the chart
now one thing you can do is
you can edit the
chart title
here by default it has shown total we
can rename it to let's say
profit
by
segment
and hit enter
okay
now you can adjust the size of this and
the color of the text if you want you
can do it from here
similarly
let's
add a title to our bar graph as well
so here if you see
there's an option to choose chart title
and
i'll say sales
by
segment
and
category
okay
similarly let's add a title to
our first line chart that we created
i'll click on the chart title
and here i'll
write sales by
year
and
region
okay
now let me go back to my
data sheet
now suppose
let's say you want to know
the total units that were sold for each
sub category of products and the
shipment mode
so here we have the shipment mode
and you want to know the total units
that were sold which is basically
this column the quantity column
for each sub categories of product you
can see we have different sub categories
like book cases chairs labels the
stables furnacings art phones binders
etc
so let's create a pivot table for this
i'll go to the insert tab
click on pivot table
and click on ok all right
now
since we want to know the total units
that were sold let's drag
the quantity column under values
and
i'll choose
the ship mode field under columns
and let's select
subcategory
under rows
so i have my pivot table ready
now based on this pivot table let's
create a line chart i'll go to the
insert tab
click on recommended charts
and let's go to line chart
all right
you can see the preview here and the
legends which show the
shipment mode let's click on okay
i close this
now
first let's remove these fields i'll
right click and i'll hide all field
buttons
now if you see this one
you can
add some styles to your chart
let's modify our chart a bit
let's see i'll select
yeah this one
you can see
it has given dots for each endpoints
which means
this is my first sub category as you can
see the second subcategory the third
subcategory which is art
then we have binders
so it's really easy to read
and understand the chart well
okay
now
let's add a chart title
i'll write
quantity
sold
by
subcategory
and
ship mode
now you can reduce the size of the
chart title text let's keep it
10
okay
now you
also have the
feature to create
different kinds of maps in excel
so suppose
you want to see the states that made the
highest and the lowest sales in the
united states so you can create a field
map for that
so first of all let's go to our data
sheet
i'll click on any cell go to insert and
create a pivot table
and click on ok
all right
so since we want the
state and the country so let me first
drag country field under rows
and then i'll choose the state field
under rows
now let's
drag sales under values
okay
so we have our
pivot table ready now if i sort this
data you can easily know
that california state made the highest
amount of sales
now if i scroll down
below you can see
north dakota made the lowest amount of
sales
now
let's do one thing let's remove the
grand total so you can go to the design
tab
and
under grand totals you can select the
first option you can see the grand total
has gone
and in order to create a map we need to
adjust this pivot table so i'll click on
united states
i'll right click and
i'll go to field settings
here under
layout and print
i'll click on
show item labels in tabular format
and i'll also click on
repeat item labels you can see
it will populate united states for all
the rows if i click on ok you can see
the united states have been populated
for all the states
now let me
select this table
or before that let's remove the
subtotal from here
i'll close this
go to the design tab
under subtotals
i'll choose do not show subtotals okay
now let's
select the table
and
i'll actually paste it somewhere here
now with this data
i can go to the insert tab
and choose maps
let's select field map
there you go
you see
we have a nice field map of the united
states
and here you can see the color scale
so it goes from light gray all the way
up to dark blue so the states that are
in dark blue
let's say california made the highest
amount of sales you can also validate it
from the pivot table
similarly the lighter the color
the amount of sales were less for that
state
now let's give a chart title here
i'll
give a chart title
as
sales by
states
and let's remove this legend
now you can format this map so here you
can change colors and
let's see if i choose this one you can
see the color has changed
and you can see the california state
is shaded in dark which means it made
the highest amount of sales
you can also
add data labels you can see it will show
the
sales values for each of the states
and if you want you can keep the legend
as well i'll just remove these two
all right
now
similarly you can also create a field
map
to see the profits by each state so you
can analyze which states made the
highest amount of profit and the state
that made the lowest amount of profit so
let's do that
i'll go to my data sheet
i'll
click on insert and select pivot table
let's click on ok
now first and foremost let's drag
country under rows
and then i'll choose state under rows
next
let's drag
the profit column under values
so i have my
pivot table ready
let's go to the design tab and remove
the subtotals
i'll select do not show subtotals if i
scroll down
okay i have my grand total now so let's
go to the design tab under grand totals
will remove it
ok
now let's just populate the united
states which is the country name for all
the rows
i'll right click on united states go to
field settings
click on layout and print
i'll choose
select item labels in tabular form and
select repeat item labels
let's click on ok
so i have my
country name populated throughout
let's
select the pivot table
i'll paste it somewhere here
and now let's go to the insert tab
i'll choose map let's select field map
there you go
now we have the
profits for each of the states
let's first delete this
and edit our chart title
which is
profit
by
states
okay
let's close this
let's say
we'll use this one now
okay let's edit the color of the chart
title
i'll make it as white
and let's say
we'll
choose the color
as
say this one
okay
now let me go ahead and remove the
legend here
and just delete it all right
so we have our
field map ready which shows profit by
each state
now that we are done with our analysis
and creating our
different pivot tables and pivot charts
let's build the final dashboard
so let's create a new sheet here
okay
the first thing i need to do is i'll go
to the view tab and i'll remove the grid
lines
all right
now let's go to the insert tab
and here we have
text
let me choose text box
let's create a text box here
okay now you can reduce the size
actually
let's reduce it
okay
and you can move it to the top
all right
let's pull this a little down
and this too little right
let's fill the text box color with
blue color
and
let's
give the text as
sales
dashboard
and we'll
give a white color to the text
and i'll select my font
you can select any font you want
so i'll go with
let's say
britannic bold
okay we have it here
and let's increase the size to
30
and we'll center align it all right
now
the next step is to
bring all our pivot charts
to this dashboard sheet
so i'll first copy my
pivot chart
and i'll paste it in sheet 8 let's paste
it here
and we can reduce the size
okay
now similarly let's do it for the
other charts as well i'll copy this and
let's paste it somewhere here
okay
now let me just reduce the
size
and if you want you can reduce the
chart title font size as well let's make
it 11
okay
and let's
drag this a bit
all right
now let's
copy the
pie chart
and let me paste it here
let's reduce the size of this pie chart
okay
see we have our pie chart here
now
let me
take my line chart which shows the
quantity sold by
different sub subcategories of product
i'll copy it
and let me paste it
somewhere here
i'll close this
and we need to reduce the size so that
we can fit in our
other charts as well
okay let me reduce a bit more
all right
now we are left with the two
maps that we created let's copy this
and
let's paste it
here
i'll go to the right
let's reduce the size
similarly we'll do it for
sales by
profit map as well
let's copy this
and
paste it onto our dashboard
let's reduce the size first
and let's increase it
towards the bottom
so we have our
dashboard ready you can see the
different
pivot charts that we created
now let's add slicers and timelines to
this dashboard so that we can filter our
tables and the charts
so i'll
click on this
first chart which is our line chart i'll
go to the insert tab here you can see
under filters we have slicers and
timeline
first let me click on timeline and here
i'll choose my order date column
let me click on ok
all right
let's drag this a bit here on to the
right
and i'll show you how you can use this
let's
first choose
years instead of months
and let me reduce the size a bit
okay
now another thing to do here is let me
right click
and i'll go to report connections
here i'll select
all my pivot tables instead of just one
so that
any manipulation you do
in the order year it will reflect for
all the
tables or the charts we have on the
dashboard i click on ok
now that we have seen how to add a
timeline
i'll reduce this a bit
let's now add a few slicers
let's click on any of the charts
i'll go to insert click on slicer
now let's add
a region slicer i'll click on ok
and let's take it to the right
will reduce the size of this region
slicer slicers are nothing but
filters which have
advanced filtering options
and
we can add
one more
filter
or a slicer let's say
we want to do this time on
the segment
so i'll go to slicer
i'll choose segment here and click on ok
so you can see i have my segment slicer
here let me just reduce the size
and
let's drag it
here
at the bottom
all right
okay
now if you want to know the sales and
profit
for a particular year so you can choose
that particular year here on the
timeline
suppose i want to know
the sales only for 2014 and 2015.
so the way to do is you can select one
of the years so i'll click on 2014
and now i'll drag this
to select 2015 as well
if i
go to left
the figures that you see only reflect
the sales and the profit for 2014 and
15.
similarly
if you mark here
or let me just bring it
to the middle
suppose say i want to
have 2016 here included as well i can
just drag it to the right
you can see the charts will change
i'll just
remove the filter and place it here
similarly if you want to
see the sales and profit for
a particular region
you can do that too
for example let me just bring this
region slicer here
and
let's say you want to know the sales and
profit only for the east region
you see here it shows only for the east
region
and suppose you want to see for east and
west region also
you can see it changes here
okay
let me just cancel this
now
you might be wondering when we selected
the different regions only the pie chart
changed
but the rest of the charts were
the same now the reason was we did not
apply this slicer to all the pivot
tables so let me right click
and go to report connections
here i'll choose
the remaining pivot tables as well
i click on ok
all right
now let me just bring this to the middle
and let's say we want to know the
sales and the profits
and the quantities sold for let's say
south region
if i select this you can see it shows
only for the south region
let's see you also want to know for the
central region
now we have selected both central and
south you can see the variations in the
graph
we cancel this
similarly we have our another slicer
which is the segment
i'll populate the slicer for
all the other pivot tables let me choose
all of them
and click on ok
i'll bring this
to the middle so that you can see the
variations in the graph let's say i want
to know the seals the units sold and the
profit for home office segment so i'll
only select home office
you can see the variations here
now the slices actually don't work for
the maps so you can't see any change
here
now suppose you want to
know for the corporate segment you can
select corporate or if you want to
select for multiple segments you can do
that as well
just cancel this
and let me place it here
all right now we are done with our demo
so if you want to get a copy of the data
set and the demo file that we are using
here in this video you can put your
email id in the comment section
our team will send you the files over
email we'll compare the two most popular
job roles in the field of information
technology that is business analyst
versus data analyst
business analyst is a professional who
bridges the gap between the it and the
business teams in an organization they
use data analytics and modern
technologies to assess processes and
deliver data-driven solutions
they understand and solve a business
problem and validate business
requirements
a business analyst generates reports for
executives and stakeholders
they are part of the business operation
and work closely with the technology
team to improve the quality of the
services being delivered they also
assist in the integration and testing of
new solutions
now let's talk about the job description
of a data analyst
with a rapid increase in data generation
today the term data analyst has found
its prominence
a data analyst collects processes and
performs analysis of large data sets
every business generates data in several
formats this data can be in the form of
customer information and feedback log
files transaction data marketing
research and so on it is the duty of a
data analyst to transform these business
data into valuable insights some of the
problems that can be addressed are how
to improve a business how to provide
good customer experience what would be
the ideal price for a new product how to
reduce transportation costs and so on
data analysts deal with data handling
data modeling and reporting with this
brief understanding of the job
description for a business analyst and a
data analyst let's now shift our focus
towards the various responsibilities of
a business analyst
a business analyst identifies the
business goals understands the problems
faced by an organization and comes up
with a cost effective solution to tackle
the issues
they thoroughly understand the
requirements from the clients and assign
the right resources bas communicate and
work closely with the development team
to design the solution for a problem
they ensure that the development team
doesn't spend their time understanding
the stakeholders requirements and often
give iterative feedback on the solution
being developed they check and validate
if the project is running fine with the
help of user acceptance testing they
also verify if the solution being worked
on is in line with the requirements and
ensure that the final product satisfies
the user expectations bas asses the
functional and non-functional
requirements
a business analyst documents the project
findings and results they present the
project conclusions to the stakeholders
and clients along with delivering
maintenance reports and building
visualizations to make decisions
now let's take a look at the
responsibilities of a data analyst
first and foremost a data analyst must
identify and understand the
organization's goal and requirements
this helps to plan and streamline the
analysis process
data analysts collect data from various
heterogeneous sources they assess the
available resources comprehend the
business problem and gather the right
data for analysis they work closely with
different team members like programmers
business analysts and data scientists
data filtering and data wrangling are
vital jobs of a data analyst the data
collected is often noisy and it contains
missing values hence it is crucial to
clean the collected data and remove
invalid values to make it ready for
analysis
they use a variety of analytical
statistical and business intelligence
tools to spot trends and patterns in
complex data sets discover hidden
insights and prepare summary reports for
the leadership team
they also use programming languages for
data mining and data manipulation
now it's time for us to understand the
difference between a business analyst
and a data analyst based on the skill
set they possess
first let's look at the skills that can
help you become a ba
a business analyst should have a
graduation degree in any relevant field
such as business accounting information
systems human resources or engineering
you can apply for entry-level business
analyst positions or with professional
experience
excel is a powerful analytics and
reporting tool for working with data
bas use excel to perform various
calculations data analysis plan and
editorial calendar and calculate
customer discounts to derive meaningful
insights and take decisions
base sql to retrieve manipulate and
analyze data stored in relational
databases
critical thinking skills are important
to understand customers business needs
it allows them to distinguish between
requirements that add value to the
business and those that should be given
a lower priority
base should find different ways to
address each challenge
data visualization is a key skill for
bas to build interactive dashboards and
reports to convey the outcomes of a
project
knowledge of tableau power bi and
qlikview is required to make different
types of reports depending on the
business requirements
business analysts should have a good
hands-on programming experience to solve
complex tasks and perform faster
analysis of data
hence knowledge of programming languages
such as r and python is a prerequisite
finally they should have good
presentation skills they should also be
confident about their findings and
conclusions and communicate it in front
of the stakeholders and clients
let's now understand the skills that a
data analyst should possess
you must have a bachelor's degree in any
relevant field or be a graduate in
statistics economics or science
you're eligible to become a data analyst
being a fresher or as an experienced
professional you should have domain
knowledge in the field you are working
in once again knowledge of excel is
another basic requirement for a data
analyst
data analysts often work with structured
data so they should be proficient in
writing sql queries using data
manipulation and data definition
commands
they should know how to create stored
procedures another crucial skill for a
data analyst is to have hands-on
experience with programming languages
such as python r sas and javascript you
can analyze and visualize large data
sets and create predictive models for
making business decisions
data analysts create data visualizations
using libraries such as matplotlib
c-bond ggplot and plotly
this helps them to perform exploratory
data analysis
knowledge of tableau and power bi is
required to create different business
reports with the help of graphs and
charts
data analysts should have knowledge of
machine learning algorithms to build
sophisticated models and make future
predictions
so they should know about linear
regression logistic regression support
vector machines k-mean clustering and
other supervised and unsupervised
learning algorithms
finally data analysts should also
possess good communication and
presentation skills
now let's discuss a salary structure for
both of these job roles
according to pay scale a business
analyst in the united states earns an
average salary of 69 000
while in india you can earn nearly 6
lakh rupees per annum now talking about
the salary of a data analyst according
to pay scale in the us a data analyst
earns an average salary of sixty
thousand seven hundred and ten dollars
per annum and in india you can earn
around four lakhs twenty four thousand
rupees per annum let's now move on and
look at the different companies hiring
for business analyst roles
here we have oracle the search engine
giant google the american mnc cognizant
and e-commerce company amazon in
addition to that we have ernest and
young technology giant ibm dell and
cisco hiring business analysts
talking about the companies hiring for
data analysts we have twitter google the
social media leader facebook and amazon
we also have the american oil company
shell the electric vehicle company tesla
apple and the american credit reporting
agency equifax
now choosing the right field that is to
become a business analyst or a data
analyst could be a challenging task
the key points that you have to keep in
mind before making a decision is
first review your background and see
what qualifications you have check what
skills you possess and the domain
knowledge you have
then gauge your interest to see what
suits you best
and finally consider your long-term
goals and see the job roles that will
help you grow in your career in the long
run
now let me tell you how simply learn can
help you grow your career as a business
analyst and a data analyst
simplylearn offers a postgraduate
program in business analysis that is in
collaboration with purdue university the
endorsed education provider is iiba some
of the skills that will be covered in
this course are strategy analysis
wireframing solution evaluation
dashboarding data visualization agile
scrum methodology scrum artifacts
statistical analysis using excel and sql
database
some of the tools covered in this course
are microsoft excel tableau power bi
jira postgresql plan box and others
some of the key features of this
business analysis program are you will
receive purdue post graduate program
certification master classes from purdue
faculty you can enroll in simply learns
job assist where you will get im jobs
pro membership for 6 months and obtain
35 iiba pd cdus and 25 pmi pdus
you will get 170 plus hours of blended
learning along with capstone projects in
three domains
to become a data analyst you can enroll
in the postgraduate program in data
analytics offered by simply learn
this program is in collaboration with
purge university and ibm
the skills that will be covered as a
part of the course are statistical
analysis using excel data analysis in
python and our data visualization using
tableau and power bi linear and logistic
regression modules clustering using
k-means
supervised learning and others
the tools that you will learn are numpy
pandas scipy scikit-learn excel and
others
some of the key features of this course
are you will get purdue post graduate
program certification industry
recognized ibm certificates enrollment
and simply learns job assist and master
classes from purdue faculty
you have 180 plus hours of blended
learning 14 plus hands-on projects on
integrated labs and capstone projects in
three domains
so please go ahead and enroll for these
programs if you want to grow your career
as a business analyst or a data analyst
business analyst interview questions
my name is richard kirschner with the
simply learn team
we'll go over some beginner intermediate
and advanced level questions to expect
in interviews when you're looking at
business
analytics
let's start with the differentiation
between a risk and an issue
and this should be a very fundamental
question uh dealing with business
because in business they want to make
money and we really want to understand
where the split is on a lot of these
things always ask yourself where is the
bottom dollar on this and what does this
mean
risk is your potential and an issue is
something that's actually happening
so risk is a potential problem that can
be predicted risk may or may not happen
in the future a proactive response plan
is formulated and kept ready to mitigate
risks
so these are things you plan for
and the issue refers to a risk that is
occurring or about to happen there's no
response plan in place to solve an issue
you can only respond reactively to an
issue what are the various tools a
business analyst works on
this is very
company
specific and so when you start looking
for work you start going in for
interviews
you should start really asking yourself
what are these companies looking for
that i'm interested in
clearly if you work with ibm you want to
have your tools that are central to ibm
and the ibm setup same thing with google
with you know just across the whole
field
some of the more basic ones
obviously an excel spreadsheet which
isn't on this list
but your python your sql you should
really know your sql it's going to come
up in no matter what format you're in uh
your tableau your xjour your balsamic
all these are different platforms
there's a lot more out there but you
should be aware on which platforms your
proficiencies are on
and those also that you might not be
proficient on but you at least know what
they do and what their performance is so
you can answer questions and
a lot of companies will pay for you to
be certified if their platform isn't on
your list
what are the various stages of a
business project
and we look at project initiation
project planning project execution
project control and monitoring project
closure and it's really important to
understand
any one of these in a little bit more
detail than just knowing the list
what is feasibility study
a feasibility study is a method of
gauging the success rate a proposed
business solution it enables business
analysts to discover new business
opportunities
and uh really a lot of businesses when
they're looking at a for a business
analyst this is really what they want to
know what's the feasibility that is a
very central question that comes up
in most business plans what's the
feasibility of doing something and
getting it done
what is business model analysis business
model analysis is a technique that helps
you analyze if a business is financially
economically and socially viable or not
i know a number of contractors that this
is their sole career is to go in and
analyze ski resorts in colorado to find
out whether it's going to make it this
year or not and what they need to do to
fix that
so it's a very high-end
job niche where you really need to know
your stuff and understand what it means
what do you understand by requirement
differentiate between requirements and
needs
we look at requirements requirement is a
targeted solution that is required to
achieve the set business objectives
business requirements are data used for
business processes
needs needs are the high level
representation of the terms and the
result
business needs include identifying and
comprehending the businesses goals and
articulating its strategic direction
and you can think of needs are what do
we need to succeed
requirements are well these are the
things we need to put into place this is
what's required to achieve a business
objective
suppose you have been given a list of
zip
pin codes
from different countries using those
codes find the city and the state names
using excel
and so if you're given a list of zip
codes pin codes of various cities from
the us and india here's how you can find
the city and the country names select
all the codes go to the data tab under
data types select geography click on the
insert data option choosing city from
the field list click on the insert data
option and select state from the field
list
really you do need to know your way
around excel no matter what other
packages you're working with
excel is such a base package in business
analysis
so much people are giving that back and
forth still it's still kind of a
baseline
below our sales data that has
information on different items sold
across various regions and countries
what was the total revenue generated for
all the items in india
you can use the sum if function to find
the total revenue generated from india
you see here equals some f and then of
course b2 to b100 india l2 to l1001 and
that will give you
the sum you can also use a filter option
to filter the data only for india and
use subtotal by pressing alt plus equals
nice short hotkey to remember there
create a highlight table to visualize
the revenue generated from offline and
online cells for different items across
the region using tableau
now not all companies use tab blue
but it is becoming a very highly used
tool because it's so easy to use
you drag the region onto columns drag
the cells channel and item type fields
onto rows select the total revenue
column and drag it on to color and label
cards select square as the mark type
drag the total revenue filled onto
columns drag the total profit column
onto rows place item type column on to
colors under the size card place a total
profit drag the region column into the
filters card and select asia
so
one of the things about tableau is it
looks real complicated but it's all drag
and drop
and so you should know your way around
about doing some very simple drag and
drops for doing your query and summation
and below is the resulted plot
so let's look at some more questions but
let's jump to a little more intermediate
level
differentiate between software
development life cycle and project life
cycle
so look a little bit more hierarchical
towards the top of the list software
development lifecycle helps with the
development of software products it
consists of a single software across
multiple phases
here phases include requirement
gathering coding operations maintenance
and documentation
where the project life cycle this
enables you to develop a new product in
the business project lifecycle consists
of multiple software in one customer
scenario
phases here are idea generation
screening development testing and
analysis
how do you perform risk management in
your project
so again we're dealing with intermediate
not just how to pull tables across we
start analyzing things and the risk
management is a technique wherein risks
are identified avoided reduced
assessed and mitigated
having the appropriate risk management
plan decreases losses and optimizes
decision making to enhance the
organization's performance how does risk
mitigation differ from risk avoidance
risk mitigation risk mitigation is a
plan to be executed when a risk occurs
when a risk occurs there might be a
business impact and the cost incurred is
high
risk avoidance whereas risk avoidance is
carried out to avoid the risk from
occurring meanwhile the business impact
here is zero and the cost is fully
eliminated and you can think about a
brick and mortar store
and they have shoplifting
you want to mitigate as you want to
avoid as much shoplifting as you can but
you can only frisk people at the door
and have security so much before you
start losing customers and so when you
mitigate it you're going to have to pay
for your lost merchandise where you
avoid it you have your security cameras
and people watching to stop
people from
stealing things
risk in this case can mean loss of money
spent
badly spent on equipment certifications
there's all kinds of areas where you
want to mitigate and avoid risk what are
project deliverables project
deliverables represent a collection of
measurable services and goods that are
to be delivered to the end user in the
project completion stage
this is so important we start talking
about any of our
when you sign a contract any of our
online contracts cloud computing all of
that make sure you're very clear what
the deliverables are who owns it who is
the responsibility of the service and
the security around it those are all
very important questions to know
differentiate between the agile and
waterfall model
two of our biggest or most basic models
used today the agile model which is
slowly taking over especially in
software
the agile model is adaptable to
requirement changes and has an
incremental approach
in the agile mile model testing can be
performed in every phase
with the waterfall model the waterfall
model is referred as a structured
software development methodology
changes and requirements are difficult
to implement meanwhile in the waterfall
model testing is performed only in the
final phase
and you can look at this as
a lot of the software today has to be
ready to change quickly when the
waterfall uh setup you're not looking
for fast changes you're looking for a
very solid
it's going to work no matter what kind
of view this is something that we can
build it doesn't have to make major
changes but it better work correctly
describe the different analytical
techniques like moscow and swat
moscow analysis is a prioritization
technique that highlights a requirements
significance question like is it a
must-have or it should have
could the demand be made better would a
specific idea be useful in the future
are asked here
in the swot analysis it discovers the
strengths and weaknesses of a firm and
evaluates them as opportunities and
threats
swot analysis consists of strengths
weaknesses opportunities and threats and
you cannot kind of think of it as like
the swat team coming in uh
to you know be worried about threats
here so we're talking about policing or
in moscow really what is um what can we
get out of this you know is this do we
have to have it to succeed is it going
to be useful in the future so you're
looking more for a general value
attached to it list various components
of strategy analysis
for developing a strategic plan for an
organization the vital components are
vision
objectives
mission strategies
action plan
what is benchmarking
benchmarking is a process of evaluating
an organization's
like the quality of policies programs
etc against the standard criteria
it's so important to have that baseline
of what are you measuring against the
baseline might not even be a very good
one but you can't measure something
unless you have something to measure
against
it helps with the measuring the
performance of the company you can
recognize the areas of improvement in a
company and analyze how other companies
achieve other objectives
what is the best approach to work with
difficult stakeholders
a business analyst interacts with many
professionals during his work few of the
best approaches to take into
consideration while working with
difficult stakeholders are
before i even jump into this i have a
friend who is working with some very
high-end individuals who took their
private plane
uh and he was supposed to meet him at
the in location
when he arrived they had been in a fist
fight while on their private plane the
stakeholders had so much difficulty with
some particular aspect going on
so difficulties are going to arise
hopefully not at that level but things
happen
and of course you want to just assume
work with anybody but you want to listen
patiently to the stakeholder's point of
view respond to them politely and
diplomatically
have a one-on-one discussion to make
things more precise
comprehend their worries and be
transparent
make sure to continuously engage such
difficult stakeholders
and i'm going to highlight the last one
because if you're working with somebody
who's difficult and you just try to
ignore them
one of the things is that whatever
problems are arising they're just going
to explode
so that is so important not to ignore
the
ignore somebody who's being difficult
but the rest of it is stay focused stay
focused on what you're trying to
accomplish
be goal driven this is a great time to
be goal driven
not driven by emotion or the problems
that arise or how the person
communicates
name the different types of agile
methodologies
scrum go get scrum certified important
thing to look into if you haven't
learn software development and extreme
programming xp
feature driven development fdd
crystal kanban dynamic systems
development method dsdm
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
there is an agile just a ton of
different methodologies so knowing at
least a few of them inside and out and
having a kind of a general idea that the
other ones are out there is important so
you at least know what we're talking
about when someone comes up and talks
about agile
describe the gap analysis
gap analysis refers to the analysis of
differences between the existing systems
functionalities and the targeted system
the gap indicates the amount of work
required to get the intended result
gap analysis is a comparison between the
current and proposed functionalities
and you can see here we put together an
action plan to go from the current state
to the desired state
how do you import text file data into ms
excel
and remember excel is one of those
things that has been around forever and
even though it's like the bottom barrel
of a lot of
analysis that we do
most of our data starts in an excel
spreadsheet
or a comma separated variable file that
you then end up with an excel
spreadsheet
given below is the employee text file it
has information about name agent company
and here's how you can import this data
into excel
go to the data tab click on get data
drop down under
from file select text csv select where
the text file is located in your system
and click on import
click on load data imported into excel
you've been given cells data that has
information on the cell of different
items across the world below is the data
create a pivot table to analyze the
profit of all the items in each region
now remember our pivot table is a table
of statistics that summarizes the data
of a more extensive table so it takes a
full data sheet and we're just going to
bring we're going to focus zoom in on
something that's what the pro the pivot
table means
if we want to go ahead and do this what
we do is go ahead and select a cell in
the table go to insert and click on
pivot table
in the create pivot table box choose
existing worksheet to place your pivot
table
drag region and item type onto rows drag
total profit onto values
sort the sum of the total profit column
using the cells table find the
percentage contribution of cosmetics to
the total revenue and total profit
create a pivot table by dragging item
type onto rows select the revenue and
profit column under values
right click on the revenue value under
show value as select percentage of grand
total right click on a profit value
under show value as choose percentage of
grand total
you can see here when we do that we end
up with cosmetics made a 14.03
contributions to the total revenue and
an 18.94 contribution to the total
profit how do you create a dual axes
chart in tableau
drag the order data onto columns and
convert it into continuous year drag
total revenue onto rows and total profit
to the right corner of the view until
you see the light green rectangle
synchronize the right axes by right
clicking on the profit axis
under the marks card change sum total
revenue to bar and sum total profit to
line and adjust the size and color
they're lots of fun to play with as you
start getting into these
using the cells data create a view to
show the total units sold and the profit
generated from each item which item sold
the police and has least profit
so we'll go ahead and load an excel file
data in tableau desktop
drag units sold onto columns and item
type column under rows place the total
profit column under color and choose the
desired color palette sort the units
sold axis in descending order
you can see here it produces a very
quick
bug figure shows the fruit sold and the
least and had the least amount of profit
create a map to show the units sold and
the profit generated from different
middle east and north africa items drag
country onto the detail card place a
total profit column under size drag
units sold under color
in the filters card drag the region
column and select middle east and north
africa
bahrain had the maximum number of units
sold at the same time iran made the full
amount of profit
create a visualization to analyze the
total revenue and the units sold for
clothes meat and baby food across
different regions in 2006 and 2017.
drag the units sold filled on the
columns drag the region and item type
fields onto rows under the cooler card
place a total revenue column drag item
type onto filters and choose close meet
and baby food drag the order date column
onto filters and select 2016 in 2017.
meat had the highest units sold and made
the maximum profit now with any of these
tableau it's good if you have your own
hands on for this
so that's an important thing to note we
kind of zoomed in on tableau again
there's a lot of other companies out
there using a lot of other packages so
if you're not familiar with tableau but
you're able to do this in another
package
that's a good thing so at least you know
what we're talking about you've had that
hands-on
let's go ahead and jump to some advanced
level questions
what is requirement prioritization name
the different techniques used for it
requirements prioritization focuses on
allocating requirements depending on the
business
urgencies this is essential for the
project to run well requirement
prioritization enables various teams to
understand what is important and work in
sync with the business needs
there are several techniques used for
requirement prioritization
we had moscow technique we mentioned
that earlier the requirements are
grouped based on must mandatory should
high priority could
not necessary but preferred and would
suggested for the future
ranking method here you give each
requirement a distinct numerical value
based on its importance
of course this is at 100
oh well here's kind of similar to
ranking is the 100 method multiple
stakeholders get a no
notional 100 to distribute among the
requirements
so the 100 method is pretty similar to
what the ranking method is
top 10 requirements and this approach
from a large set the stakeholders simply
picked their top 10 requirements
this is very popular there's a lot of
help books out there about getting
things done they say write everything
that you want to accomplish
put them on three by five cards and
narrow it down to five
do those five because once you've
conquered those five then you can move
on to the next ones
name the critical agile metrics that
should be considered by a business
analyst
sprint burned down
so the sprint burned down is the chart
we use when you're tracking usually it's
in scrum is where that usually comes
from the scrum uh setup uh but it's a
chart of the work to be completed and
what's still going on
uh you have your work category
allocation the velocity
the cumulative flow diagram defect
removal awareness
time coverage defect resolution time
explain
bpmn
bpmn business process model and notation
gateway controls the flow of interaction
and sequence of processes it is a
flowchart technique which models the
end-to-end business process step
the four essential elements of bpmn are
flow objects events activities gateways
connecting objects sequence messages
associations
swim lanes pool or lane
artifacts data object group annotation
list the elicitation techniques the
elicitation process is about gathering
requirements from users and stakeholders
listed below are a few techniques that
are used to collaborate with users or
clients
interviews uh during how many times i've
been on the phone calling uh competition
um potential clients to ask questions
uh so
one of the elicitation techniques is to
ask questions if you're going to call
clients to ask questions a lot of terms
also turn into additional sales
document analysis
focus group
prototyping
brainstorming my favorite brainstorming
all these are important i just kind of
highlight a few of them that i tend to
get stuck in
observations and workshops
again workshops are a great sales
technique also so as you're doing your
business analysis
and you're bringing people into a
workshop and do observations in the
workshop and working specifically with
these people they turn into potential
business growth
i tell you what if you're a shareholder
and someone's doing a business analysis
and they turn around
and generate a 30 000 sell for your
company um they're in you know you've
already earned your you've already
earned your pay and you're doing what
you like which is business analysis
interface analysis questionnaire and
survey uh questionnaire survey is my
least favorite but they are the most
popular because they're the easiest to
pump
out list the documents needed by a
business analyst
initiation document
project vision document
use cases
system requirements
specifications
document business requirement document
requirements traceability matrix
functional requirement document
use case specifications document
gap analyst document
describe how you would approach a
project
here's a basic project approach outline
which you can use with respect to
different situations
identifying the project goal formulating
the work plan defining the requirements
collaborating with other teams
tracking the project documenting the
progress
and really when you
start
designing your project approach
encompassing all the things listed in
here so important with the shareholders
if you i mean it's great if you can
identify your project goal and that's
probably the most important thing
because if you don't have a goal
you might as well walk away
but if you don't have the rest well how
are you formulating the work plan
defining the requirements um
collaborating with other teams that is
such a big step
because we're going from everything
being on paper and trying to figure out
what you're going to do to actually
doing it and then tracking and finally
documenting very important for the
shareholders and what goes back to the
top
differentiate an alternate flow and
exception flow in a use case diagram
from a basic flow
basic flow represents the operation of
activities as required by the company
in a use case alternate flow as the name
suggests is an alternate solution used
in a system failure case
different steps are used to complete the
goals of a use cases
exception flow refers to the various
steps executed in case of errors
this does not lead to achieving the
required goal of a use case
critical aspects of creating analytical
reporting analytical reporting is a type
of business reporting which provides
data analysis information and
recommendations it enables people to use
data to make decisions
to create analytical reporting the
following points should be kept in mind
comprehend business analysis
display your analysis skills think
critically
and i'm going to throw in here the term
from big data map and reduce
really when we're doing a business
analysis
you don't want to give them a massive
amount of information you want to reduce
it down to something that they can see
in a single graph a very simple set of
notes
um and you need to think critically you
need to really make it
what is it that the shareholders want
that's going to make them understand why
this is important to the business and
what does the business get out of it
what is kanban
kanban helps agile teams in visually
managing work through processes it works
as a scheduling system in agile just in
time production the kanban methodology
is all about real-time communication of
capacity and full transparency of work
the kanban board describes a current
development status
and of course when you're working with
kanban you got to be very careful about
[Music]
inspiring versus coaching versus
micromanaging
it really can end up in a micro
management setup where you want to you
want to watch out for that but you also
need to track everything
a basic kanban board has three-step
workflow as the to do in progress and
done
however depending on a team size
structure and objectives the workflow
can be mapped to meet any particular
team's unique process
state the key differences between brd
and srs
brd business requirements documents is a
high-level functional specification of
software
brd is a formal document to describe the
requirement provided by the client
business analysts create this post their
interaction with the clients
srs
system requirement specification is a
high level functional and technical
specification of software
srs describes the software's functions
and non-functional requirements that are
needed to be developed whereas srs is
created by the systems architects
what is pareto analysis the pareto
analysis helps in crucial decision
making it helps in prioritizing
decisions identifying the most
relevant and the least decision
concerning the overall goal
it is also known as the 80 20 rule
as per this rule 82 percent of the
project's benefit arises from twenty
percent of the work
vice versa eighty percent of the case
problem can be due to twenty percent of
the causes
differentiate between the v model and
the fish
model we talk about the v model it is an
sdlc model where the execution of
processes happens sequentially in a v
shape
at every stage the same person reviews
but other testers will do software
testing in the last step v model
consumes less time and costs
the fish model is similar to the v model
but with more multiple verification
teams
every stage is tested by another team
for completeness and correctness the
fish model is comparatively very costly
and time-consuming
which makes sense because if you have
multiple tests on each stage for
multiple teams they have to all be spun
up on it and so you're literally more
than doubling the work because you also
have to track all that
given the sales data create a chart to
show each region's country that made the
highest revenue create a pivot table by
dragging the region and country onto
rows place the total revenue column
under values
right click on the country value select
the filter options and choose top 10.
choose top one as shown above and click
on ok
and you can see here is the pivot table
that you will get
using the cells data find all the
countries where the total units of
fruits sold offline were less than 3
000.
you need to use an advanced filter
option in microsoft excel to solve this
problem
below is a critical based on the
question we have go to the data tab
select advanced filter option choose
copy to another location
give your criteria range and the copy to
location click on ok
here's the final result as we can see
below
let's create a pivot table to find which
countries from each region made the
lowest amount profit
create a pivot table by dragging the
region and the country into rows place
the profit column under values right
click on any country value select the
filter option and choose top ten choose
bottom one and click on ok
let's create a filled map to analyze the
total revenue and profit generated from
beverages in north america using tableau
drag country under detail card place a
total revenue column under the text drag
total profit under kalur and the filters
card drag the region column and select
north america
in the filters card drag the item type
column and select beverages
and you can see from the below map you
can see that greenland and the maximum
revenue and profit generated from
beverages in north america
who knew
using tableau how will you display the
top five and bottom five items based on
profit
drag the item type filled under rows and
total profit onto columns right click on
the item type column to create a set
give a name to the set and select the
top tab to choose the top five items by
sum total profit
create a set for the bottom five items
by some total profit select both the
sets right click to create a combined
set give a name to the set and choose
all members in both sets drag the new
set on the filters and the total profit
onto calor
the above graph depicts the cosmetics
made the highest profit while fruits
made the lowest
and really when we're talking about
tools like tableau
or if you're targeting companies working
in r
or you're targeting companies working in
python
you should be able to quickly do these
kind of displays in any of those
packages that you're focused on
tableau is one of the biggest ones out
there right now because it is a paid for
service but it's also
very robust and easy to use and uses
less programming on the back end so just
a quick side note on there really just
leads up if you if this does not look
right to you you're not able to get
through some of these things make sure
you are if that's what you're targeting
in a company for an interview in this
video we will learn everything from
basics to advanced in excel our
experience instructor ajay will help you
learn in detail
you will start off by taking a tour to
welcome to excel where you will learn
the basics then you will understand the
various crucial functions available in
excel such as vlookup hlookup sumifs
counters if error and others
you will learn how to sort and filter
data in excel
then we'll focus on conditional
formatting and data validation
moving further you will get an idea how
to create pivot tables in pure charts in
excel
and finally you will see how to use the
data analysis tool pack to perform
various data analysis operations such as
regression sampling descriptive
statistics and much more over to ajay
now hi everyone
welcome to this tutorial on microsoft
excel so
we will learn about functions and
formulas we will learn about conditional
formatting data validation pivot chart
and pivot table
now let's look at the scenario here so
one day in a startup
one professional speaks that their
business is growing and they would need
an efficient way to work with the data
they would have to find a way to work
faster with storing and analyzing data
now to that another colleague responds
well we can make use of microsoft excel
to do this job
the question is will excel be able to
cater to
their business needs
now
the colleague responds well we can make
use of excel in several ways and it also
is a cost efficient
option
now in that case the colleague who posed
the question
says let's go ahead with excellent let's
train our employees in excel
and
the suggestion is welcomed which would
make the job easier for them
and they would basically
decide on using excel so they decide on
taking a training right away and
basically starting to learn excel
now
before we move to excel one of the
question is why should we use excel
so let's look at some of the points here
so excel proves to be a great platform
to perform various mathematical
calculation on large data sets which is
one of the biggest requirements of
various organizations these days various
features in excel like searching sorting
filtering makes it easier for you to
play with the data
and excel also allows you to beautify
your data and present it
in the form of charts tables and data
bars
now when it comes to reporting reporting
accounting and analysis can be performed
with the help of excel
it can help you with your task lists
your calendars and goal planning
worksheets
excel also provides good security for
your data excel files have the feature
of password protection
this way your information can be safe
now when we talk about what is excel and
how it can be used
so excel or you might have heard a
spreadsheet can be basically used for
a lot of different tasks than just
storing the information in so called
tabular format
now microsoft excel is an application
that is used for recording analyzing and
visualizing data it is in the form of a
spreadsheet
let's have a look at few of the
functions and formulas used in excel and
before we do that we can also quickly
take a
small tour to understand how to work
with excel
now to do that what we can do is we can
type in in our search say for example
excel
and just select your excel app which is
installed and here you see you have a
lot of options which says take a tour
drop down list get started with formulas
make your pivot table
going forward with pie charts and much
more so we can click on this one which
says take a tour
and that basically pops up a window
which says welcome to excel and
if you have always wanted to be better
at excel
you have this
which can help you so let's click on
create and that takes us to the store
window now that says instructions for
screen readers which basically talks
about 10 different steps in which we can
learn excel
and using the spreadsheet app
so there are more than 11 sheets which
we see here at the bottom end and each
one gives us a simple example which we
can work on
so for example if i click on add
now that takes me to this page which
says
how do we add numbers now you might be
provided data which we can
upload by loading a file from our
machine or getting data from a web
source or even connecting to a database
so there are various options which we
will see in some time
so here we have an option which is
called data you can click on this one
and this basically has
options where you can use existing
connections if you have created some you
can always click on from other sources
and you can get your data from sql
server from analysis services
from odata data feed you can get in from
xml from data connection wizard or also
from microsoft query you can be running
in different queries here which shows up
in the option which says new query there
are connections which you can use and
that basically will display all the
connections
for this particular workbook which we
did not have as of now but we can create
them but let's look at simple examples
now you can follow these instructions
here which says basically
adding up the numbers and that could be
easily done by just placing your cursor
here and what you could do is either you
can type in the formula that is from
which row to which row you would want to
add the data so for example i could just
do a sum here and that shows up all the
different functions which are available
then we can open up a parenthesis and we
can say i would be interested in
totaling the amount
from
column d and i would select for example
d4
so
i could be doing this and then i could
say d4
onwards till d7 so that's the data which
i'm interested in you can close your
parenthesis and hit enter and that gives
you the total
there is also a shortcut for this which
you can always do is we can first delete
this and you can just place your cursor
here and just
use your alt and equals that
automatically selects the numericals
which we can anytime
expand
or basically collapse so i will
basically select this which says this
function needs two numbers which is
number one and number two and then you
can hit on enter and that gives you the
total
so similarly we can be getting in the
data
here by selecting all the fields
so here it also says that you can use a
shortcut now what we can also do is we
can add numbers over 50
by selecting the yellow cell here and
then giving a condition
such as so i can basically use something
like sum if
and then open a paranthesis i can select
i would be interested in this row and
then i can even drag and drop
till here so that tells me d11 to be 15
you can then put in a comma here and you
can give your condition say for example
we would say i would be interested in
numbers only above 50 and we can select
this
close your quotes and then just close
your parenthesis and that's your formula
so you can do this and that basically
gives me the total is hundred now
similarly we could do that for the
amount here i could select this now
there is also an option i can click on
home
and i can go for something like auto sum
so that's one more way of doing it which
anyway says
sum is alt plus equals so it
automatically adds up your values and i
can try doing a auto sum
that automatically selects my rows and
then i can get my total now as per this
activity here it says try adding another
sum if formula here but add amounts that
are less than 100 and the result should
be 160. so what we can do is we can
basically
select all the numbers which are lesser
than 100 so the way we did earlier here
there can be always a shortcut so you
can always for example if you would want
to avoid typing in the formula you can
always copy it from here
and then
just hit on enter so you are back into
this cell and then i can basically go
here and paste
the number and then as per the
requirement we are required to select
anything which is lesser than 100 so
what i could do is i could select here i
could say let's say g
and then i can change this value to g15
and that's one more way now we see our
selected rows have been changed so i can
hit on enter and
i can check what is the result so we
would be interested in
looking for numbers which are lesser
than 100 so i will have to also change
this one to a lesser sign and that
basically gives me the total which is
160
so that's how you can simply add numbers
you can use autosum you can type in the
formula you can select the fields or you
can just place your cursor where you
would be looking for a sum and then you
can just do a alt equals and that
basically populates the sum
now let's look at
some easy options of filling your cells
or automatically populating the values
in your
cells within your excel sheet
now here we have an option with says 100
now we can click on this and that
basically says it is making a sum of
column c4 to d4
so if i click on this one i can check
that this is
row number 4
which shows up here
and i also know this is column c i also
have d so this equals is basically
giving me a sum of c4 to d4 now what we
can do is we can always place our cursor
here at the right corner and then we can
just drag and drop and this basically
gives me a total of all the numbers for
all different rows
so this is one shortcut which we can do
to get the total excel will
automatically give the totals which we
call as filling down
now what we can do is in the same way if
we would want to get the totals here we
can first check what is this 200 and
this tells me it is c11 to c14 total so
it is totaling the rows from c11 so
column c and eleventh row till
fourteenth row and that's the sum now
what i can also do is i can similarly
like above we can do a filling right
which basically means bringing your
cursor here and then just dragging and
dropping it all the way where you would
need the totals and this basically gives
me the total there is one more quick way
to check if this is right
so the easiest option would be
to select this cell now what i can also
do is i can just select all of these
fields by just highlighting and
selecting all the fields once it is
selected
press on ctrl r
and that gives you the total now if we
would be doing this top down then i
could select all these
rows
for this particular column and then i
could do a control d so that's your
filling down and this one was filling
right so this is an easier option of
doing a fill when you would want to have
the formula applied to every row as it
occurs in the first row or the last row
we could test this by for example
selecting these fields i could delete
them and i have here which says 130 i
could just place my cursor here and i
could drag it all the way up and that
should also do the same
magic which we were seeing from top down
so this is a simple way wherein you can
fill up your cells and you can also
automatically
propagate
or move your computation to all the
cells
let's
look at the split option which basically
helps us in splitting the data when we
have some kind of pattern or when we
have some kind of delimiters in our data
in say one particular column and we
would want to derive the values out of
it so we can always use the splitting
option now the easiest option would be
so for example we have our email column
which has the email ids and which we can
clearly see has a first name dot last
name now i see that there is a last name
smith filled up here first name is empty
so what i can also do is i can just type
in say
nancy here
now that's the first name i can again
start typing the second name and as soon
as you do that you would see a faded
list of numbers and that's your clue to
hit enter and once you do that you would
see all the first names have been filled
in here if you would want to maintain
the case sensitiveness you can just go
ahead and delete these and let's type in
as it occurs so let's say nancy as the
first name go down to the next cell and
just type in andy and there is your
grade list so just hit on enter and that
basically fills up your first name what
we can also do is
we can just select this particular field
and either we can type in control e
which basically fills up all the options
now i can just do a undo by typing in or
clicking control z
and that's basically gone
what i can also do is i can select a
particular field and then i can go into
home option and under home
you should have an option here which
says fill so you can select this and
then you can do a flash fill which is
what we are doing here so click on flash
fill and that automatically fills up the
values so in this way you can work
within your spreadsheet and you can be
filling up the values where a delimiter
by default is understood and we can
split the data now however sometimes you
might have some data which has a
different kind of delimiter
and there is again a smarter way of
splitting your data
so you can always scroll down here and
that says splitting a column based on
delimiters so we have some values in the
data column and
these values in each row are separated
by comma so
select this
your data is already selected text to
columns delimited
comma is selected
and now click on next so it basically
says
what is the destination let's select
this one
and i can choose
what would you want to have so that
shows me this would be my data preview
now i can basically select this one
i can say finish
and say okay
and now if you see our data has been
placed in
in the columns appropriately so this is
how you can split your data based on a
delimiter and then organize your data in
a better way now there are some advanced
options which we can learn later but
this basically tells about using a
formula so this is something if say if
we have some name in one cell and if you
would want to split it into first name
your helper column
your middle name last name so that can
also be done using formulas and this
basically tells
how would you extract characters from
your left
cell and how would you place them in
your right cell so you can try this
activity which is a little more of
advanced option the benefit is that you
can always use this
wherein
if you
do some kind of transformation using
your formulas if your original data gets
updated then the split data will also
get updated and that's the benefit of
using formulas where you can place
values from one cell into multiple cells
based on execution of your details in
the formulas
how about using the transpose option now
you might have heard of situations where
you would want to
switch or turn your rows into columns
and your columns into rows and that's
where transposing comes into picture it
might be useful when you have your data
in your x and y axis or as i would say
in rows and columns and you would want
to switch your rows to become the
columns and columns to become
your rows so what we can do is the
simplest way is you can
select all your
values so here we basically have six
columns and i would say two rows now i
can select all of these and then i can
select an empty field for example the
one which is highlighted here well you
can always do a control alt v that's a
shortcut what you can also do is
once you have selected all your fields
you can just copy them so just do a
control c
and then click on an empty cell and then
what you can do is you can do a special
paste or paste special so under your
home
you have the paste option and here you
can go for paste special
and once you do that you need to select
the transpose option over here and click
on ok
and now you will see that the columns
and the rows have been transposed so
your row name was item and that has
become the column heading you had row
name as amount and that has become the
column heading and all your values have
been transposed
in
this particular format now there is
another way of doing that and again
that's using your formulas so what you
can do is you can transpose with a
formula also and that basically
works
when you have
similar kind of data so this has six
columns
and basically two rows so you can
basically do this so you can
select this and earlier we were doing a
copy but now what we would want to do is
we would want to just look at the row
numbers which tells me it is c 33 c 34
and it starts with c and ends in with
your h column so what we can do is we
know that we have six columns and two
rows so transposing that would actually
give me two columns and six rows so what
we can do is we can select
two columns
and six rows in our excel sheet i can
then basically start typing in the
message or i can just go to the address
bar and here i can say
transpose
let's go for c33 h34 it basically
selects my data
and now i can just do a
control shift and enter and now if you
see all the values have been populated
now you can just place your cursor in
one of the cells but if you see the
address bar the formula remains the same
this is because this is an array formula
so we can read more about an array
formula here it's basically something
which performs calculations and on more
than one cell in an array and in the
example here the array is the original
data that is c33 to h34
so your transpose is just changing
the horizontal orientation to the
vertical orientation so this is a very
simple way in which you can basically
use the excels capability to transpose
your data and convert your rows into
columns and columns into rows apart from
working on
additions subtractions filling up your
data sorting
the data or basically splitting your
data
transposing your data one of the other
requirements is
sorting and filtering your data now that
can be very handy when you're working on
huge data
and you would want to sort it in a
particular order say ascending or
descending or might be based on a
particular field or if that field was or
if the cell was highlighted with a
particular color sorting the data so
let's look at how excel can be used for
sorting and filtering examples are
pretty simple here so
let's check that so if we're going to
sort and filter and say this is the data
i have say for example i would want to
sort the values in the department column
alphabetically so what i can do is i can
select department column and i'm already
in the home tab i can straight away go
here which says sort and filter
i can then say sort a to z and that's
basically alphabetically sorting your
department column
and once once i do this you would see
the data has been sorted but it's not
just this data we can just do a ctrl z
and check what are the values we have so
here we have meat which is beef and
ninety thousand
hundred ten thousand the values
then you have bakery which should
ideally be the first
row if we sort it in alphabetical order
which goes with bakery as desserts you
have the values so we can check this
again so select department and then just
do a sort and filter and let's say sort
a to z and if you see the data has
changed but it's not just in changing
your first column but then it has taken
care of all the data however the data
has been sorted based on the department
column so you have bakery which aligns
with deserts which has the values and
now we have all the data which has been
filtered now what we can also do is we
can sort december's amounts from largest
to smallest so what we can do is we can
basically click any cell in the december
column let's say 20 000
and then what i can do is i can go into
sort
filter and then i can say sort largest
to smallest so if you see bakery breads
is the row which has the smallest data
or might be you have delhi sandwiches so
that one looks also smaller so let's do
a
larger to smallest and if i do this you
would see the values have been shifted
now so it is no more based on the
department column
because now the data is being sorted
based on the values in the december
column and you see bakery which was
alphabetically the first one has become
second last
so either you can sort the data based on
a department column which goes based on
the values these are all string values
or words so it sorts alphabetically if
you have numbers might be you can give
some values and you can sort the data
you could anytime do a custom sort and
you could basically select
if you would want to select the data so
i could do a custom sort and then i
could choose
which is the column which we would want
to use for sorting what is the sorting
needs to be done
is itself values is its cell color font
color conditional formatting and then
you can also choose the order so that's
one more way to do that now if you
scroll down that also shows how you can
sort by date or a color so for example
if you would want to sort
based on the expense date so there are
different options so what i can do is i
can select this date field i can just do
a right click i can go into sort and
then i can choose i would want to sort
oldest to newest so since i selected the
date field it basically has sorted all
the data
and it has taken the expense date into
consideration now there are these
filters which you see on the row
headings we could have also used those
so i could have selected this and that
basically says or mentions which are the
dates i would be interested in looking
at
i also have sort by color here i can do
a sort oldest to newest or newest to s
so i could also use these filters which
have been applied here now we have the
data which is in color so if i would
want to basically select
the color columns or color cells i could
select this i can basically do a right
click here and when i go into sort i
could choose put selected color or cell
color on the top and that basically will
make sure that my data is sorted and it
has also sorted that in a descending
order so in this way you can sort or
basically filter your data what we can
also do is we can add filters so
sometimes we can go for formulas which
we would want to use what we can also do
is we can
basically select the filter which has
been applied here now how does the
filter come in there so if i would
select a particular row i could select a
particular row and then i could decide
if i would want to just add a filter to
this one and that's how the filter has
come in so we have the filter what we
can do is we can basically click on this
drop down and then you have something
like number filters so we can always go
here we can basically choose one of
these so we can basically choose above
average so i could select this and then
basically it shows me the values we
could also delete the filter by clicking
on this one and we could say well i'm
not interested in this filter anymore so
i could clear the filter and that shows
me all the values
or i could say
that
let's click on some other field for
example food i can go in here i can go
into number filters and then i could say
well i'm interested in
values which are below average above
average might be greater than and then i
can choose what is the value so for
example if we say i'm interested in food
which is
greater than 25 dollars i could give a
value here i could say okay and now i
have applied the filter similarly you
can select this and then you can just
clear your filter and your data is back
so remember
no data is lost
it is just hidden or basically based on
the filter not shown
so that's good enough for us and in this
way you can sort and filter the data so
for more details obviously in all the
sheets you have the links which point to
more information on the web and you can
always refer to these so this is simple
way in which you can sort and filter any
amount of data
which has been stored within your excel
within a particular sheet now that we
have learned about add fill split
transpose sorting and filtering it will
also be good to learn how to work with
tables or basically converting your data
into a tabular format and then doing
some easy computations so click on this
tables option here now here we see there
is some data which is in
five columns and n number of rows so i
can basically select this data
and then what i can do is i can insert
choose the table option
and then it says my table as headers and
we'll be okay with that i'll say okay
and now if you see this is the table
created it basically has different
filters which we have learned earlier
how to use
and this is basically my table which is
a collection of cells which has some
special features
so we can easily add rows to this table
we can add columns to this table and we
can even do some calculations so for
example here
i can click on this one i can
basically enter some field and then i
can hit on enter and we see that this
row has been inserted wherein we can
easily fill in values for example i
would say chocolates
i could give some value here size 25 000
might be 35 000
and then
basically i can given some values here
now what you can also do is you can
continue adding rows in this way
and say for example you would want more
columns so you can select this
option here in the top bottom right
corner you can just drag it towards the
right and that basically has
automatically created
columns for my next months
wherein i can feed in the data so this
is a simpler way wherein you can keep
adding more rows and columns to your
data if that has been converted in a
tabular format
now let me just do a ctrl z that
basically deletes the columns again
control z deletes the last row which we
added and i can stop here or i can even
remove my values by doing multiple
control z and removing my rows so this
is how
i converted my data into a table and
then i can easily work on this what i
can also do is i can do some
calculations so what we can do
we have a table here we have a total
field and what we can do is we can just
select one cell here now as we have
learned earlier we can do a alt and then
equals
and that basically says what
is this doing so it says it is
calculating the sum of
the last three months and if that's what
you would want to do just hit on enter
and it has automatically calculated
the totals for all your rows for these
three columns
so the sum formula is getting filled up
now i can select any particular cell and
i can look in my address bar so it has
already given me the formula where it
has started
calculating the sum from the october
column till the december column and has
given me the calculated values of the
columns what we can also do is we can
get total rows in the table now that's a
simpler option so what we can do is we
can select any cell in this particular
table
and then
we see that there is a table tools
design option showing up here now i can
select this and then it says well let's
get a total row so let's select this and
it automatically populates the total
here
and if you would want the average then
we could select this and from the drop
down i can select what i'm interested in
so for example i would want the average
values and not the total i could just
select this and that gives me the
average of these values
so we can always do simpler computations
here
by converting our data into table format
let's learn about one more efficient way
of working with the data and that's
using your drop downs so let's see how
drop downs work here
now
say for example you have this data which
has the values in the food column and
department is empty and say for example
you would want to
enter the values in department however
you would want to select the department
should either have
produce or meat and bakery and these are
the only three options which should be
available for any user to fill in the
values how do we do that so we can
basically create a table by pressing
ctrl d so what i can do is under my
department
here i can select one of the cells and
then i can do a control t that basically
converts this into a table i can say ok
and my table is created now what i can
do is once this part is done
we can
select all the blank fields here where
we would want this drop down to be
applicable
now under your data tab you can go in
and select data validation
and this has an option called data
validation click on this
which basically says allow any value so
here i will select i would want to give
a list of values and then i can type in
my values here which i can say produce
say for example meet and then say
bakery now these are the values
so we can click on ok
and once we have done that we basically
have a drop down here next to apples
which will only show us the values which
we can feed in under the department
column so i can go into every cell and
then i can basically choose
what is the department which handles
this
and then basically i can select one of
these from the drop down so this is an
easier option of creating your drop down
and then feeding in the values from the
set of values which you have defined
here on the right
so this is a simple example of using
your drop downs
working with your tables working with
your sort and filter transpose split
filling up your data adding in some data
here and similarly you can use excel for
more than
one use case using its inbuilt features
to easily work with your data
let's see how we can import data or
bring in data into our excel from
your local machine or from an external
web source
so
what we can do is we can open up a blank
excel sheet and say for example you have
been provided
a text file or a csv file and you would
want to import that data into your excel
sheet that can be easily done
so right now i've opened an
excel sheet now i can click on data and
here i have an option which says
existing connections from other data
sources
so or you can click on connections if
you have already created some so we can
click on from other sources
so this is one option where you can
connect to your different data sources
and you can get the data
from one of these
what we can also do is i can click on
connections now it says there is none i
can click on add it says
well show the connections where
connection files on
network connection files on this
computer so i can say let's get some
files from this computer
now if that does not show up something
so say browse for more and that
basically shows you different options so
let's basically select a folder where i
have
some data sets i'll click in here
and this is basically a folder where i
have some data sets now let me select
this particular file and i know it is a
csv file
so let's click on
open now if you would want to verify
this you could have gone and looked into
the properties of the file and it says
it is a dot csv file which is what we
are interested in so i'll take this file
i'll say open now this basically shows
me
the text import wizard option which says
is the file delimited i'll say yes
click on next so i will select comma as
my delimiter i can say text qualifier is
none
now this is my data so my data preview
is already showing me the data is what
is the data in the csv file
you can click on next and then you have
an option which says data format is
general you can go for date format you
can go for advanced options so i'll just
say finish and basically now this has
been created here
so we basically have this and now i can
click on
close now once you have done that you
can click on existing connections it
shows me the data
which we have here the connection which
we have created say open
and then it says do you want to
import this data or bring this data into
existing worksheet
you can also say add this to a data
model if you are doing some data
modeling so click on ok
and now this data is automatically
inserted in my excel file i can
basically save it
into
this particular sheet now what we can
also do is we can also start a new sheet
and that does not have a data and we can
get some other data from web so what i
can do is i can go into my github
and let's say i would be interested in
this csv file so i can select this
and this is my github path a path on web
so i can click on draw and that
basically gives me
the raw path where this particular file
is now you can select this
copy this particular path
and here you can come back to your excel
sheet we would be interested in getting
the data from web might be from a text
file where we will have to specify the
delimiters or let's go to web
and here
i can given the web path from where i
would be interested in getting the file
let's give the github path which is
publicly available and then click on
import now once you click on import it
tells me there are two fields data and
value
these are
within double quotes separated by comma
so first let's click on import
now once we do this it will basically
get the data from web and put in here it
says existing worksheet so we had
already created a new worksheet so let's
click on ok
and now you have the data coming in but
then this basically shows me in one
particular field so what we can also do
is we can just do a control a that
selects all my columns here
and that's my data so we can then
basically
filter this out so we can say text to
columns
it's a delimited file click on next
we can select comma and
let the text qualifier be quotes
it shows me data
preview click on next
so you have the general format
it shows the destination that's the
column
click on finish and now your data has
been split and you have the data which
you have imported from web so this is
the data which is coming in from web
this is the data which came in from my
local machine and similarly we can even
create connection with an existing
database so i can basically click on
connections if i would want to do that
so i have an option called connection
here
and it says where the selected
connections are used
i can basically click on add
i can basically choose
if i would want to get the files from
network or from computer like we did
earlier i can click on browse for more
which should
show me
different other options to create
connections say you would want to create
a new sql server connection you can
connect to a new data source coming in
from different place you could basically
choose what kind of connection you would
you want so these are all the different
options which we can go for
and we can basically connect to a
database for example if i have some
database
and say for example access database
i can see if there are some files with
that particular database and i can
import it
so similarly we can also
uh click in here which says new query
and that also gives you an option of
getting the data from your files from
all these folders
from databases so you can basically
click here and then you can import data
from a mysql database provided that is
set up on your local machine or on a
particular server you can go from cloud
you can get it from online services you
can get it from other sources which says
from web
from your hadoop file system from active
directory from a blank query and you can
even combine queries wherein you can run
a power query editor
you can get the data from different
sources and then you can bring it into
your excel so in this way you can get
your data from different sources into
your excel into your spreadsheet and
then you can continue working on those
data sets
we have
already learned some basic operations
which you can do in excel and let's
implement our knowledge by working on
this particular data which is coming in
from housing data set now here if we see
some fields we have agent
date listed area list price and this is
basically the data which has been
sorted in newest to oldest order of date
listed
so how do we
arrive at this so what i can do is i can
just click on data listed
and then i can either
go in here
i can select sort i can get into custom
sort
and then i can choose the column
based on which i would want to sort the
data so i would look for the newest data
to the oldest data that means that would
be in a descending order of dates or you
could say the oldest date or the
earliest month will be towards the lower
side of your sheet so here we can select
date listed now i can say let it sort
based on cell values and the order what
we have here so we have newest to oldest
so let's select this
i can say okay and now if you see the
date has been sorted so we have your
10 18 2007 on the top so that seems to
be the latest date and as we go down we
will see
an earlier month hour
and
earlier month than that in this date
listed so we have sorted our data
into
newest to oldest order and that's based
on your date column so the result shows
up here now what we can also do is we
can have different questions which we
would want to answer so for example i
would want to sort the data in ascending
order of area
and descending order of agent name how
do we do that so let's look into this so
this is here i already have the result
here and how did i get this so i'm
looking for ascending order of area in
descending order of agent name so we can
start with any particular column that
does not matter so for example if i look
into this excel sheet i have my agent
name select this which we want in a
descending order
so we could either do a sort and then go
for
descending sort z to a we could also use
the filter option here on the top right
and we could do it or i could just say
sort z to a and then it
has arranged the data
based on the agent column being in
descending order now i can go into area
and then i can again do a sort and i
wanted my area column
to be used for
sorting the data ascending to descending
and that basically not only changes the
order of this particular column but for
my complete data so let's do that
and now if you see we have the
data which has been sorted so
we can see how many values we have here
and the area values which we see and
this is how you get your result
so i'll just do a ctrl z and
again and i'm back to my original data
and this is the sorted result which we
are seeing at
similarly we can answer other questions
for example sort the data according to
the following order
of area
that is we are saying county
central
and then your county so we can basically
choose
in which particular way we would want to
do it so it is county central and then
again county so if i look into my sheet
3 so here
i basically have my data which is
having some south county
then you have your central and then you
have your north county so we would want
to
sort the data to solve our problem which
is
according to the following order so
first we go for area then we go for
south county central and north county so
what we can do is we can basically
have area field selected
and i would want to sort this particular
data
so i have south county central and north
county so i can basically go for custom
sort
and then i can choose which is the value
or column which i'm interested in let's
go for area
we will go for something like
cell values well you can also try to
explore conditional formatting icon
if this is what you would want to use
or we can basically go for just sell
values
and here we can say
if i would be interested in first
getting my values for
south county so
for example i can say custom list
and then i can basically given the new
list here so i can say s
dot
county
and then i would want
central and then i would want north
county
so let's select this
as it exists
we can
basically say add
and that's basically the order which we
want to say okay
and then say okay here
and now what we would want is we would
want our data so we can compare that
with the values which we see here it
starts with kelly you have in the 12th
row something like lang and that's what
we are doing so we can basically arrange
the data in a particular order by
choosing a custom list and then sorting
your data
so that's one more simpler task of what
we have done
where we have sorted the data
in the order
where
under our area column we first wanted
south county
then we wanted central data and then we
wanted north county so this is how you
can do it
now
let's look into one more problem so it
says find all the houses in the central
area
and we would want to basically apply a
regular filter let's let's see how do we
do that so we can click on this and here
we have the data so the problem
statement is we would want to find all
the houses in central area
now how do we do that we can do a
sorting but
we would want to use the filter which
you see here
is implemented so how do you do it so
you can select this area and say for
example i would want to apply filter i
can just go in here and i can say let's
get a filter on my first row and now i
have filters applied so we are
interested in looking into the central
area houses let's go in here it says
all these fields are selected that means
it shows everything
wherein your area has all these values
let's unselect this and then i will only
be interested in the central so let's
say okay
and then say okay so now you see that
the area
filter has been applied and we are
looking at the central column so what we
have done is we have applied a simple
filter and we are looking at our data at
any point of time if you do not
want
the filter
then
what i can do is i can select this and i
can say well i'm interested in all the
data
so i could do this or you can clear the
filters from area
and you get your data back
so
that's in one way you can filter out
your data so let's look at an example of
sort and filter where we might have to
filter the data based on two columns or
multiple columns with different kind of
values where it could be and and or
condition now say for example this is
the data i have and this is the question
which we need to answer such as find the
list of all houses
in the central region with pool
and south county without pool now if it
was a simple filter based on one cell i
could have
just selected my
header row
i could have then applied the filter
and once i have the filter i can look in
area where i have three regions so i'm
only interested in central and south
county so i can get rid of north county
and that's fine but then
we have two different conditions here so
we need
the data in central region to have
the value for pool being true
and for south county the value has to be
without pool now how do we
do that so what we can do is we can
first create a copy of these headers
here
so let me do that now the area has to be
south county so basically i can
either just select this and i can choose
this value
and then i can select this and then i
can choose central so that's the
criteria which i have and the pool value
has to be
so central region should be with pool so
then this one
basically has to be true
and
this one has to be basically false so
south county is without pool so let's
select one of the values here and this
is my criteria now
to get my result
we can always place your cursor here and
you can check this is m column and
eighth row
okay so we would want the result here so
let's go ahead and now click on data
and then in filter you have an option
called advanced
and here what i can do is i can say i
would want to filter the list in the
place but that's not what i would want
to do so i'll say copy to another
location and here if you see the list
range will tell me
that this is the data so a1 to j126 so a
to j column selected and all the rows
criteria range is basically based on
what i've given here so that is
m from 1
to v
which is 3
so i'm selecting these columns and then
i'm saying all the way whatever criteria
i've given and copy 2 i'm saying m8
to v8 so that basically will give me my
filtered result so you could basically
just say okay
and now i have my data which has been
filtered
and i have my area which is south county
that is without pool central with pool
again south county without pool
and then if you look at your central
value that's pool so this is an advanced
filter which we have applied where
simply we have filtered the data based
on two columns and then we have our
result so in this way you can have your
customized filter applied on two
different columns and get your data
which can be either
replacing the existing content or
in the same sheet in different set of
columns and rows you can have your
result let's look at one more example of
filtering where you are trying to filter
the data based on an and condition
condition being met in two different
columns and then you would want to
filter out
the data for only specific columns so
the situation is the agents with a house
in north county that should be county
area having two
and a single type family so we are
talking about two bedrooms
and
we would basically have a single type
family and here the criteria is that we
would want to
only populate these columns which is
agent area bedroom and type now what you
can do is as i explained earlier that
you can get your result in
the same sheet in a different location
so here i have created these headers
which says agent area bedrooms and type
now this is basically a copy of all the
columns what we have here agent data
listed area list price bedrooms bath
square feet and so on so you can
basically create a copy of the headers
here and this is where we will give our
advanced criteria to filter the data
so the conditions which need to be met
is we need to look at north county
so for example here in area i can
basically go ahead and select one of the
values north county
now the criteria is having two bedrooms
only so let's say
bedrooms and let's say the value should
be 2
and then basically i am saying a single
type family so when you would want the
single type family so here under type i
can give the criteria
single type
so
this is my and condition so we are
saying north county area having two
bedrooms and the type is single family
now this is the criteria which basically
means if i select this this one tells me
that this is m
one row onwards till v
two
so this is what we have and we would
want to filter based on this
so let's go ahead and then go for data
filter advanced
and here in advanced it says filter the
list in place now that's not what we
would want to do so i'll say copy to
another location
this basically selects the list range so
which is telling me
a1
to j126
so that's the
columns and rows selected criteria range
is based on m1 v2 which we have given
here and copy to i would say for example
from m7
to
p7 now this is the area where i would
this is the place where i want the
result let's say okay and now i get my
data which is
based on the question which has been
asked that you would want the agents
with a house in north county area having
two bedrooms and single type family so
in this way you can basically do
advanced filtering
get your data and get it stored in the
sheet anywhere at a different location
well i could have also done filtering in
place and that would have replaced the
data
which we have but that's not what we
want we would want the filtered result
in a different place so this is how you
can do some advanced filtering we can
also use excel to filter out the data in
one particular column which might be
conditional or say
using some numerical filters now here
say for example the problem statement is
that you would want to display all the
houses whose list price is between
45 000 to 600 000
or say for example we would want to
filter out the data to something else
say for example let's say i have
i would want to filter out the data
between 300 000 and 400 000 so we can
basically
update this
say for example i'm saying i'm
interested in 300
000
to
400
000 and that's the criteria to filter
out the data now there are two different
ways or there are two easier ways to do
it one is
i would want to
look at the list price so i can select
this
i can go ahead and do a filter here
and in the list price now this is where
we would want to do the filtering so
it's pretty easy you can click on this
one and then you can go into number
filters and you can choose between now
that's one easier way of doing it so i
could basically select this i could say
i am looking for value which is greater
than or equal to 300 000
and then is less than or equal to 400
000 so if i just do this
i have applied my filter and i have my
data which is filtered based on my
criteria right so that's one easier way
of doing it or let me do a control
z
now
let the filter be there which you can
anyways use but what we can also do is
as we have seen earlier methods so get a
set or get your column headers here
and then you are giving two columns here
now the only difference between
my
this set of columns which i have one two
three four and then you have seven and
ten columns and if you see here
we have 4
5
6 7 8 9 10 11 right so whenever you want
a and condition you will basically
add the columns where i can give add
condition if it is the same column if it
was a different column then it would be
same number of columns but and
conditions will lie in the same line and
all condition would lie in a different
line now here i can give this value so i
am looking for listed price
being
between 300 000 so i am saying it should
be greater than or equal to
300 thousand and then i can say less
than or equal to
four hundred thousand now that's my
criteria
and then i need my result here which is
an m seven
so what i can do is once i have given my
criteria which i'll be using
to filter i can get into data i can go
it into advanced
and then i can say copy to another
location so it is selecting my a1 to
j126
criteria range is based on m1 to
w2
and then i would want my result from
this particular column
so let's say okay and now you have your
data filtered out in a different
location in the sheet
which has been filtered based on your
and condition so you can filter out the
data in this way or you could just apply
a filter on a column and give the
conditions
now let's solve one more interesting
problem and here we would want to use
excel where we would have an and and
an or condition so say for example this
is the data given to you and the
question is that you would want to find
all the houses in north county again
that's a spelling mistake but then the
north county area with a list price
greater than 300 000
and having three or four bedrooms so the
bedroom
has conditional so it has or three and
four
and then basically you have
list price which is greater than three
hundred thousand now i could have
obviously
selected the columns and then basically
gone for a filter
so i can just do a filtering here
and then i'm looking for list price
being greater than 300 000 so which we
can always give a number filter and i
can say greater than
and then i can say
greater than or equal so i can say
greater than and then i can give
thirty three hundred thousand
and that's basically the filter which we
would want
and
here i would want to select the bedrooms
which should be just either three or
four
so if for example here i go in here and
i unselect this and then i say three and
four
right so i am getting my data which is
greater than three hundred thousand and
it should have the bettering values
which will be
either three or four selected now that's
one way of doing it let's do a ctrl z
and get it back
to as we were or you can even just say
clear filter so you get your data back
as it was so what we can do is we can
here
give the criteria
so for example i have my
list price now this is what i would want
as a condition so let's say greater than
three hundred thousand
three hundred thousand and bedrooms
should be three
and then i can say greater than three
hundred thousand
and then i can say four
so this one basically gives me a
situation where your list price has to
be greater than three hundred thousand
and bedroom should be either three or
four so we have given our filtering
criteria now to get the result what we
can do is we can go into data we can go
into advanced
and we can say copy to another location
so our list range is selected which is
columns a to j
row number 1 to 126. your criteria range
is given in m1 to v3
where we have specified and we are
saying the result would be in m7 to v7
so if i do this now i have got the same
data which we were seeing earlier and
here the bedroom values are 3 or 4
and basically the list price is greater
than 300 000 so this is a simpler way in
which you can create your filters and
all this advanced filtering what we are
seeing it will be saved with your sheet
you can always go back and change this
value or you could do filtering where
one person has to look into the filter
to see what values have been selected
now that we have looked into
some operations which we can perform in
excel using filter or sorting the data
creating your tables let's also quickly
look at functions and formulas which can
be used
for
doing some easy calculations or
computations now excel can be used in
different kind of data analysis so for
example you have different inbuilt
functions which can be used and we can
always check for a particular function
so for example if i had
if i wanted to look at a particular
function
i could just
type in here
something for example is and then it
shows me all the possible functions and
you can always have a look at the detail
of the function for example you have is
even which will return true if the
number is even
if we would say is logical
so i could search for
is logical and that tells me whether a
value is logical value true or false and
returns your value true and false
now we can
obviously
say subtotal
so you can search for any of these
useful functions and that tells me what
this function can be used for so returns
a subtotal in a list or a database
you have many other such functions such
as integer sum
average
you may be interested in working on
truncating
some data getting the absolute value
getting the square root
basically getting a count or getting a
max value you can look for any
particular functions within your excel
sheet
now you also have other functions such
as now
or time for example let's look at now
function
so i can search for
now
and here it is
so this is returns the current date and
time formatted as a date and time so
this is the function which we would want
to use
and if i just give the function it tells
me what is the current time
let's first look at the description of
time here so
say for example i would want time it
says converts hours minutes and seconds
given as numbers to an excel serial
number formatted with the time format so
for example if i would say
2 hours
and then
30 minutes
and 30 seconds and if i do this it has
basically converted this into your time
format so you can always use different
inbuilt functions for your work now we
will also look at some advanced
functions like sum a for some ifs
you have count f and count ifs
and you can be working on various
functionalities
of excel to
easily help you in doing some
calculations computations working with
your data
working with your different cell values
so let's look at some example of using
functions like sum or sum if so for that
let's go to this sheet and here we have
some data now i have already applied a
filter which can allow me to filter out
the data so it says find the total units
that were sold in the east region now we
know
that in region we have east
and
i have multiple regions i could
basically be
saying unselect all and select only east
and say okay and that basically gives me
the units which were sold and if i place
my cursor here
and then if i did a auto sum
so it would basically give me
the function which is being used so
something like subtotal and it is
basically working on
your
rows which is e2 to e44
and here
we can just do this so that gives me the
total but this is this is
fine you could do that but
it would be good if we know how do we
use a function like sum if to do that so
here i'm seeing this is the subtotal
where i'm looking at the values and
basically what i have done is i have
filtered out the region
and
then basically i am getting a count but
this does not give me clearly how a sum
was calculated from all the values which
were listed what we can also do is let's
do a control z and let's get it back
so now we have our data and we would
want to get the total units that were
sold in the east region so what i can do
is i can start typing in my formula
and for that i'll use an inbuilt
function so for example i would be
interested in going for sumif now it
says sumif adds the cells specified by a
given condition or criteria when you
talk about some ifs this is
when you could give set of conditions or
multiple criteria so let's look at some
if
let's do this now obviously this gives
me an error because the formula
is not right so we have to basically
come in here and let's start with sum
if now when i say sum if it shows me
there is a function with
sumif which we would want to use
and here
once i open up the bracket it tells me
okay what is the range of data which you
are interested in so i'm interested in
all the units that were sold in the east
region so we are interested in the
region
which is here
so
i can basically be
selecting this
and this tells me
you are interested in the data here so
let's not take the header value so let's
say b2
and then we can
go all the way to the end so we can
basically select this way
that's the data we have select this and
hit
enter
so
now here
it has selected b2 to b4 but we need to
basically now give the criteria so the
criteria is either a value or you can
point it to a cell
which has that particular value so as
per our problem statement we are looking
for the units which are sold in east
region so i can select the value east
here
and then
my sumif needs the range on which you
want to
calculate a sum so
let's select this and now we are
interested in finding out the sum of
units so that's basically this column e
column so i can basically type in
instead of selecting so i can say e
and i'm interested in e2 2
e
44 so that basically selects the area
or all the values and now let's do this
so that basically gives me the sum is
691
right now this is the criteria where i
have pointed it to a cell and whatever
value that cell has well i could have
done
something like this so i could have
selected east
giving the value
and then doing it it still does the same
thing and in this way you have more
clarity that you are using sumif you are
filtering the data so you have given the
rows
you are given the criteria and then you
have given the range
on which you would want to sum up the
values
now similarly if the question was what
was the total revenue generated from
binder
now
we would want to find out what is the
total revenue generated from binders
that means
my filtering criteria will be binder
and then
i want to find out the total revenue
generated so we have the revenue
generated field also here and we have we
don't have any region to be filtered we
are just looking for binder so let's
again start doing the same thing so we
can go for some if we can open the
bracket now it needs the range
so we are interested in
revenue generated now that's the
summation we want and we would want to
get the range of data so here
we can basically select
so that's the data selected now i would
want to give the filtering criteria so
let's say binder
and then we need to give the range on
which the sum needs to be calculated so
that's my
revenue column so that's g
so i can say g
2
2g
44
and that basically selects the column
and then you get your sum so it tells me
what is the total revenue generated from
binder
now i could be doing this for other
things also so say for example if you
would want to filter out something else
you could basically just drag and drop
here and then i could come here and
change this to say
instead of binder i would be interested
in say
pencil
if that's the criteria you're interested
in
remember to change this so that you take
all the values
and here we will change
it to select the relevant rows
and then this is the data i am getting
so i know that this is
the revenue generated
from pencil this is the revenue
generated from binder now this is a
simple use case where we are using some
if
what if we would want to use some ifs
so some ifs
let's have a look at how we get to some
ifs
so some f says where you would want to
work on
doing some calculation but then you
would want
multiple criterias to be met so let's
see how we get this
so
here what i can do is
let's work on this problem statement
which says what is the total revenue
generated from central region
where the item is a pencil
so
that's
something which i would want to check
now when we are answering this question
we can also look at the order in which
things have been asked in the question
so it says what is the total
revenue generated from central region so
we need the total revenue generated we
know there is a revenue column we are
interested in getting the total revenue
generated
we are saying
the
filtering criteria is central region
and we say in that we would be
interested only in the item
if it is pencil how do i do it so i can
use sumifs where you can pass in
multiple criteria so let's start with
some ifs
and when i start with some ifs let's
open up the bracket so it says sum range
it says criteria range
then it gives one criteria and you can
give in any number of criterias so for
example we are interested in total
revenue generated now that's my g column
so let's follow in the same order so
let's say g
2
so that's my first value and then i know
there are 44 rows here so i can say g
44 and you can obviously check
if that has selected all the rows
now
that's my total revenue generated so i
would want the total revenue generated
so i'm saying setting this sum range
then
i need to give the criteria range so it
says from central region so central
region
comes into column 2 that's b
so let's say b
2 to b 44
so that's my criteria range
then you have to give
your criteria but
we need to filter out the region being
central so let's select this now either
i could point to a value in the cell or
i can just
give the exact value here
we can also give a
wildcard or matching pattern so that
also works now this one is fine
we are now also interested in finding
the total revenue generated when the
region is central and the item is pencil
how do we do that so for
item we know the columns the column is
d2
so let's select d2
2
d
44
so that basically selects
all the rows in the d column and we need
to give the
filtering criteria so let's do a comma
and then
just given our value so let's say pencil
and then let's close your bracket and
that basically gives you the result
so
we need to just follow the order of our
question which says
what is the total revenue generated so
we are looking at the revenue column we
are selecting all the rows
then it says
from the central region so we need to
select the region column and give the
filtering criteria as central or point
to a cell which contains that value
and then it says we would be interested
only in item being pencil
so then you select the column which has
all the items and provide your filtering
criteria that is pencil
so that's your
easy calculation of using sum if which
we compare with
sum if here so sum if here was
just
having
your criteria
so basically you are selecting your rows
giving your filtering criteria and then
your sum range in some ifs we are giving
multiple condition now same thing can be
done here it says how many units were
sold by sales representative johns
or jones
where the cost of each item was greater
than four
so how many units were sold
by
sales representative
so when we talk about
how many units that's your e column
so let's start with that so let's say
some ifs
i would be interested in e
column
then let's give the range
so it says sum range so those are the
number of units on which we would want
to find
the sum
then it says you need to give the
criteria range so we say sales
representative where the name is
jones
so sales representative is in sales rep
column c so let's say c2
to c44
now
then we need to give our filtering
criteria so let's say jones
is the sales representative where we are
interested
about whom we are interested in
and then we
the question says where the cost of each
item
so cost of each item is what we are
interested in
you have unit cost
so that's what we are interested in so
that would be f
and then say f2 to f44
then you need to give your cost
so it says where each item
is greater than
4
so let's select this
and let's
do this so this tells me three zero one
now
similarly let's answer our third
question which says how many units did
jones sell excluding
pencil item so we would want to find out
what was the total number of unique
units that were sold
and
that
units or that should not include the
pencil item how do we start doing this
so let's start with sum ifs
now we know that you start with some ifs
you need to give the sum range so we are
interested in the number of units
so let's basically go in and select
our
number of units which were sold so
that's your column e
so i can say e2 to e44 that's where i
would want to perform this sum
now i'm saying
how many units that were sold where
we are talking about sales rep being
jones so let's see let's select the
columns
c
and then give
the range
after that we need to give our giving
filtering criteria which is jones and
then we are interested in
the items but excluding pencil so items
is in column d so let's say d
to d 44
and then
we have to give
our
criteria so we can say
well that should exclude
pencil
so i can basically say
pencil
and let's close this
and let's check so that's my formula
which says
that these are the number of units which
the sales representative whose name is
jones had
sold and that does not include pencil as
an item let's also look at an example of
using countif or countifs
now both of these can be very useful
when you would want to calculate certain
values
so for example if i would want to work
on count if let's try solving this
problem
now remember you can answer these
questions using filters and that can be
an easier way but then sometimes you may
want to
get the formulas so that you can make
your spreadsheet and your calculation
more
dynamic in nature and that will
basically depend on the values in the
columns or rows so for example
if i have find the total number of times
gil has made a sale now if i look at my
data here
it tells me that for every sales
representative there is some value
in the sale and it says sales has
greater than three
so for example jones you have sales
greater than three
or
you have jardine which is sales greater
than 3 and so on so what we are
interested in
is
doing a quick count in finding out the
total number of times gil has made a
sale how do we do that so we can use
this count if function and if i go into
count f it says counts the number of
cells within a range that meet the given
condition now what's our condition our
condition is kill and we would want to
find out how many times the name say
gill appears or kill has made a sale now
i could just say count if and then open
up a bracket i need to give a range so
let's say we are interested in looking
at the range
so let's say
we will choose
sales rep so i can say c
and then i can say c 2
to
c c44
now
that's my
range
let's not give that in quotes
so you have to give a range so let's do
a count if that selects the data and
then we need to give the condition so
for example let's here give the name
which is gil
and then
close this so that basically tells me it
is five times kill appears here we can
check this so i can go in here i can
add a filter
and then might be i would be interested
interested in looking at only gill
and that basically gives me five
right so we can always do that and we
can be using formulas like this now what
about this question so which basically
says which sales representative made a
sale more than three times now we it
might be looking a little confusing when
i say for example let me clear out this
filter
now we have sales greater than three and
we would want to find out
which sales representative made a sale
more than three times
now i could basically check for every
sales representative here if they have
made a sale more than three times and
what i can do is i can just say equals i
can start with count if
then i need
my
filtering criteria so that's your range
so first thing is we will choose for
example let's choose c2
to see 44
and then we need to
give and criteria what is the criteria
we need basically a sales representative
so i can choose the value here
in c2
and then
i can close this
and then i can say the sale has to be
greater than 3
and let's check so it tells me the
boolean value that yes
this guy has made
sales more than three times and what we
can do is we can just
drag and drop which basically gives me
the value for other sales rep you can
always check the value is automatically
changing to this value in cell
and for example let's go in here so this
is obviously two so it says me false
right and you can basically get the
values for all your values
so that basically tells me which
sales representative has made a sale
more than three times
now like some ifs we also have countifs
where you can give multiple criterias so
for example the question is how many
orders were placed from the east region
after this particular date so we have
a date criteria we also have the region
criteria and we need to basically
get the count of number of orders which
were placed now i can in this case use
count
ifs
and this basically says that you can
start within criteria so it says how
many orders were placed from east region
after
particular date so date is in my
first column so for example
i could say a
start with 2
and say for example let's go a 44
that should have selected all the rows
and then
i need to
once i've given the criteria range i
need to give the criteria so we are
saying
the date has to be greater than
10th feb
so let's give it
2
10
2019
and then you need to say
how many orders were placed so you need
to give the criteria second criteria
range
so we are looking at the number of
orders which were placed
from the east region
so when i would want to look at the
region that's your column b
so i can basically say b2 to b 44
and here
i would basically
give my criteria so the criteria is east
let's give that
and once you have done this you would
want to find out the total number of
orders so let's select this and if i do
this it tells me 13
now is that right so we are looking for
your date
your region being east and then getting
the total number of orders so here i can
just to account if
i'm saying 82
to a 44
wherein i have given the date criteria
that it should be greater than
10th feb because i do not want to count
10th feb it says after 10 february
and then you are saying the region has
to be east
so we would want to find out the total
number of orders so
my region is east and that gives me the
result
now similarly you can also find out how
many times gill
sold pencils so
here we will have to give the range so
let's start with count
ifs
now here i would want
that item is pencils so we can as well
select column
d2
d 44
then you have to give your criteria so
that's your
pencil
and then we are looking for sales rep
which is kill so
that is my column c
so let's say c 2
2 c
44
and the value should be
just kill
so it tells me
it's twice where gil has sold pencils so
we can obviously check this by
going in here
choosing my filter
and then let's search for rep being just
gill
okay and now we are interested only in
the item being pencil
so i can say well let's get to pencil
only and that tells me twice
so you can obviously re-verify using
filters but using functions or using
formulas
it is always good to calculate and that
can be
making your computation and calculation
more dynamic
let's look at one more interesting
feature of excel and that's your
conditional formatting now as you see on
the screen
conditional formatting has different
rules which can be applied on your data
and that allows you to basically
differentiate or easily identify data
values which
are
based on certain criterias or rules so
when you talk about conditional
formatting you have different options
such as you can highlight cell rules you
can get top and bottom values you can
apply different rules apply different
color scales and you
you can easily manage these rules
so conditional formatting is very useful
for people who would want to work on
huge amount of data and easily perform
some data analysis
it's easy to use as it is shown here and
with your conditional formatting
you can format cells based on a preset
condition
you can perform conditional formatting
to identify cells
you can highlight a few significant
cells and you can easily perform
conditional formatting
as shown
on the left side
now how do we work with conditional
formatting let's have a quick look
so say for example we have our excel
sheet and if you see here
i am highlighting
the sales person who have generated
revenue greater than 10 000
so
we can be looking at the values where
the revenue generated by a particular
sales person is greater than 10 000 it
has a particular
color
and how do we get here so for example
let's select this data
and what i could do is
i could go into conditional formatting
now i could basically highlight cell
rules and we could just say greater than
that's an easier way i could also go
ahead and create a new rule but then i
can use one of this option i can say
greater than
and let's give some value might be we
would be interested in looking at
any value greater than twelve thousand
so let's choose twelve
thousand
and here
it says what color would you want to
select so for example
i would say something like
yellow filled with dark yellow text
and let's say okay
so right now what i'm doing is
i have all the values where the revenue
generator was greater than 10 000
but then i have also selected all the
sales
people who have made or who have
generated revenue greater than 12 000.
so i can just do a ctrl z to see the
previous result now here
i had the values which were greater than
10 000
and the one which we did just now
basically
highlighted the values which are greater
than twelve thousand so this is one
simple example now we can look at some
other examples say for example you want
to format cells using three color scale
so if you look at the values here i have
a three color scale mainly in green
yellow and red and how do you do this so
for example i can go in here
and i can go to conditional formatting
so i would want to
go for color scales and here
you can create different rules so
we can set up a two color scale so we
can say format
only values that are above and below
average i can format only cells that
contain something
i can get the top and bottom values so
these are different ways in which
i can
have a three color based scale now what
i will do is i will select this
and let me show you the rule which i
have so for example
i can go into manage rules and if you
see here there are certain rules which
have been specified now what does that
mean so you would want to specify a
three grade scale
so for example if i would want to look
at my first rule
it tells me that i am choosing three
color scale i can choose lowest value
percentile and highest value and that
basically will
select the cells based on their values
so what we could have done is i can
basically
use one of these values i can delete
these rules which i have created
so for example
i have all these rules but you should
always carefully remember that the rules
will be applied in the order shown so
for example if i just
delete these rules
and then say apply and say okay my data
is back now
it does not have any highlighting now i
can go in here
i can say condition sorry conditional
formatting
i could go for color scale so i could
basically go into
new rule
so i would want
the
cells to be using three color scale so
let's
choose three color scale now when you
say three color scale it says what will
be the color of lowest value
and we could choose might be any one of
this let's choose red
i can say midpoint is percentile 50
and then the highest value is green and
if that looks good let's say okay and
now if you see the lowest values have
been highlighted as red
you have mid values and then
you have the positive value so this is a
three color scale and that
easily helps me in identifying the data
based on the cell values
now in conditional formatting what you
can also do is you can
basically color the cells based on their
value so what we are seeing here
is if the revenue
generated is greater than average
then that shows in green
and if the revenue generated is lesser
than average that's shows in orange now
how do we do that so we can basically
again manage some rules so i can
basically create a new rule
now here i can select one of the options
which says format only values that are
above or below average and that's the
option i would want to select
now i can select this and it says format
values that are above average
so
in our case we had it in green so for
example i'll say above average and then
here i can go for
a particular color
so you can go for a particular size
so
let's go and look into
the formatting
so for example let's choose yellow
say okay now i'm saying
wherever
the cell values are above average it
would be yellow instead of green
and let's go in here
let's go and look into manage rules so
this is
basically the rule which we are applying
now we can also add a new rule
and
i need to
select the values so for example i will
say
here so we had gone for above now we'll
go for below
we'll go for format we will choose red
we'll say okay we'll say
now
these are
basically
the rules which we have created and here
it says applies to your data so right
now it has not been applied so for
example if i select this and then
i could basically
choose my area just hit on enter
and similarly you can go in here and
then select your area
hit on enter and say apply say okay and
now if you see
i have really chosen bright colors but
then i have said wherever my revenue
generated is above average
it should be in yellow and
below average should be in red so we
wanted above
average to be in green and below average
to be in orange so
that's what we have here right so you
can always
color code your cell values based on
some rules which you are setting up now
similarly you can also
find the top 10 and bottom 10 values and
that's pretty easy so you can just
select this
and then you can go into conditional
formatting you can go for top and bottom
values top 10 items bottom 10 items
or you can go in for more rules so you
can say format only top or bottom ranked
values so you have top 10
now you can choose the color
and for example
i'll go for
blue
and
i'll say okay
so now if you see my top 10 values are
blue now similarly i can add one more
rule so i can say new rule and i can say
let's go for top or bottom
let's go for bottom let's go for format
let's say orange
say okay
say okay and that's it so now you have
your values which are top or bottom 10
values
so you are using conditional formatting
where you are
basically highlighting your cell values
based on different colors
and here
easy conditional formatting based on
different rules helps us to do that now
similarly you can also
have the values
which is basically
showing you how the values are
increasing
so what
we can do is we can select our
columns
either you could apply this to all the
columns now here i have applied this
only to jan and april now i could apply
this for june so let's say june so you
can go for gradient fill you can go for
solid fill
you can obviously just select the color
and that takes care of the things
you can say for example select this and
now this is selected but i would want to
might be format this so i can go in here
i can go into manage rules now that will
tell me
what rule has been applied
in the order so i can just do a edit
rule and that basically says this is a
solid fill
which is color
you have no border this is basically
color is black now i can go for
something like gradient fill
and i can say okay and now if i say
apply and okay so this basically is like
your first column so you can use
conditional formatting for various use
cases and you can highlight the values
so anyone who would look at the value
would automatically notice which are the
higher values which are lower values
might be
here the revenue is getting generated or
was getting generated but did not grow
beyond a particular value
and so on
now similarly you can also go in for
different options
say for example here we would want to
see if the revenue was dropping
or if the revenue was
if the revenue decreased
or say for example if the revenue was
going up for this particular sales
person so here we are looking at carol
so in jan the revenue generation by
sales was very high
then in feb it was falling down
in march it was
kind of stable
then in april it went way below so we
can obviously work
on this wherein we can grade our cell
values so what we can do is we can
go in for
highlighting the cell values now
you can go for color scales you can go
for icon sets
and this is where you can choose your
different shapes
so you could choose one of these shapes
so for example
i would be interested in looking at the
indicators like directional
i could go
using this three arrows i can go in for
this color
i can choose directional and then
my values are
automatically
using directional now what we can also
do is we can then go into manage rules
and that basically tells me what rules
have been applied so for example the
latest one is the icon set which i have
chosen it shows the selected columns i
can obviously do a edit rule and then i
can choose so i'm saying the format
style is
icon sets
i'm not using a data bar i'm not using
color scale
now here
i have chosen the style of icons
and then here
you can basically give some values so
you have icon which is green
when the value is greater than or equal
to 67 percentage
when i say
hyphen or minus it is less than 67
it's way below 33 percentage
then you give this value so you can
obviously edit and easily
highlight your cell values based on this
icon set so i can apply this and that's
how i use conditional formatting so
conditional formatting can be very
useful if you would want to use icon set
if you want to use your data bars if you
would want to
highlight particular values
if you would want to color code based on
some calculation
if you would want to
use a three color or a two color scale
or if you would want to just find out
values based on some simple calculation
so conditional formatting is used
extensively by data analysts
or people who are working business
intelligence teams or people who would
want to use excel
to easily identify the data
easily identify the cells which contain
particular value
or finding out less significant or more
significant cells
to then pull out values and carry out
your computations calculations
or analysis
let's continue learning on using excel
for various things now we have learnt on
conditional formatting and seen how that
can be very helpful
let's learn one more feature of excel
and that's basically your data
validation now this can be very useful
when you would want to work on
validating the data which is being fed
in the cells so you could limit it to
basically a number between a particular
value you could also add some messages
to it
if you would want
or you could even
circle invalid data or clear validation
circles so data validation really helps
us in validating the data which is being
fed in to particular fields
now it's a feature in excel which is
mainly used to control what a user can
fill in a cell you can decide what type
of values must be entered
you can also
restrict user to enter only valid data
and if any invalid data is entered an
error message will be displayed
now that's where you can use your data
validations so let's see how that can be
done so for data validation let's see
some exercises here so for example you
have a name column and you would want to
restrict
that the name should accept only 15
characters now how do you do that so you
can basically select the cells
or
you can just select a particular cell
and then we can later drag
the property to other fields now here
once the cell is selected so for example
let's try this out and let's see if that
works so for example i will say peter
johnson
okay and that is basically five and nine
and 12 characters so let's say
junior
and if i do this it says
input length is greater than 15 do you
want to continue if i say yes
right so basically
it is allowing me to add the value here
but then it has
basically violated the rule
now this is giving a message to the user
that the username should be entered
less than 15 characters now how do we do
that
so for this we can basically
select the column and then we can search
for data tab
and get into data validation
so this is where you can create or
select different kind of rules so for
example i can go into data validation
i can go into settings and i can say the
text length
and that should be less than 15 now this
is the maximum i'm giving and it says
apply these changes to all other cells
within the same settings
so i can do this or i can just drag and
drop so i can basically
apply this formula and now you can in
fact randomly check in any particular
cell is the rule applied so it says text
length less than 15. so we can basically
control data validation in this
particular column
and that will allow only 15 characters
it will pop up a message
if the user really wants to go beyond
the particular limit
now you also have similarly date of
birth so the restriction is date of
birth should be between 10 jan 1990 to
30 december 1998.
so this is what we want to restrict how
do we do that so we can select the field
we can click on data validation and if
you see here i have selected date and
then date is between and then obviously
you can give a range
that is 10 jan date
1990
12 30 1998 so that's the start and the
end filter which has been applied
and once this is done you can also check
your input messages which says
when cell is selected show this input
message enter a valid date
so if you see here on the left there is
a pop-up which is coming up it says
enter a valid date now i can also say
when user enters invalid data show this
error alert so i can say stop
i can say invalid entered
and this is how i have set a rule so for
example if i just do
something like this
and that says invalidate entered i can
do a retry it will take me back here but
unless and until
i did not
give the right format the date will not
be accepted and again the same thing
applies to all the cells
similarly email so we are saying the
email should have at the rate present in
the value provided now for this we can
use a formula and we can select well i
would want to apply this rule to
all these rows starting from c2 to c14
so let's get into data validation let's
look in settings and here we are
choosing custom
now within custom i am choosing
what is the formula so i am saying is
number
and then i am saying find
at the rate for
the rows c2 to c14 so the only thing we
are concerned about here is the value
should have an email
icon
you can input a particular message you
can say what has to be done for
error alert so for example we can
basically go in here and we can say
invalid email
that's the title i'm giving and we can
say
email
should contain
at the rate
so if i do this and if i say okay now
you can test it so you can say abcd
and that says email should contain at
the rate and basically that will not
allow me to add the values so now you
have the field called salary it says
salary should be greater than 50 000 now
we can limit the values by
choosing
a whole number so for example for salary
i can go into data validation i can go
into settings so here i can say
something like
decimal or i can go for whole number so
both of the things are fine it depends
on what kind of values get into this
particular field
so if i say whole number and if i say it
has to be greater than 50 000
so i'm saying the minimum is 50 000
or i could have given a decimal and then
i can say greater than less than equal
or anything or even between so i can
select greater than and then i can just
say okay
now for rank the rule is rank should be
between 100 and 200
so again we can use a whole number so
ranks will
generally not be decimal so this would
be whole number salary
is
can be a whole number or it could be
decimals so we have chosen decimal here
and in rank if you click on data
validation i have chosen whole number
i have set data between 100 and 200
input message nothing error alert
nothing but that depends i can give this
so this is how you can just do a simple
data validation and control the values
which land in the cell okay so now let's
also understand how we can
restrict the values in a particular cell
which might be
based on a list of items
now for example here if you see i have
two columns
so one column basically has the values
of city
names and then you have places within
that particular city so if i would want
to
implement a data validation based on
this so for example if you see here city
and that basically shows me only the
four values which can be entered and if
i go to place then it tells me for
maharashtra i can only enter pune mumbai
nasik now how do i do this so say for
example you take an empty field and you
want to restrict the values of city
names so i could
select data validation i could basically
select list
and then it tells me you need to enter
the list values that is the source so
you click here and then i can just
select these fields now if i do this and
if i say ok
it has implemented a data validation but
if you look into this
it will show me
the same thing but then it shows me some
empty cells
which did not have any value so this is
fine
but it would be better if we do it in a
different way so i can select this and
i've already given my city names here so
i can just do a data validation
and here in the source
let me get rid of this
now
i can just
have my cursor here
i can select these values and then if i
say okay so now if you see my city names
have been restricted to these values and
that's how you can implement your data
validation
so i have
this data validation here but i will get
rid of this one by just doing a control
z
now i'll come here and say for example i
would want to implement the same data
validation now the easiest way would be
in
doing this for all my four cities now if
you see here i have
data validation i could choose bangalore
and if you come and check here there is
no data validation but we have
implemented data validation here now how
is that done so i could select this or
for example i can go in here i can
select data validation
i can select list
and then here in the source
i will say for bangalore the value
should be these
and then
if i basically say ok
now
if we see these are the values which are
fed into bangalore
so we could do this or like what we have
done here so if you can check the data
validation rule
i have used list and then i have said
indirect
f2 so basically i'm giving in a formula
which relates to the value which is in
for the city maharashtra so we could do
this or in a simpler way we could do
this and then just drag and drop here so
we could check for maharashtra what are
the values
let's choose a different city so for
example kolkata and here i will choose
now since we did a drag and drop it has
basically taken the values of bank load
so that's not right so we select this we
go into data validation and here i can
either
feed in the values that is such as
bangalore i could basically say
something like this kolkata
and i could say okay
so now if you see it shows me the places
in kolkata
now here we have let's choose a
different city so for example let's go
for delhi
and here i can go to data validation and
i can just say delhi
so this is an easier way of doing it or
if you remember the formula
then what you can do is
you can just give in
indirect
and then basically
give the
value of the cell for which you would
want to
keep in the values so this is how you
can do list validation so you can
provide a list of values and then you
can restrict the values in a cell which
should be
belonging to a particular list
so this is how you do a simple data
validation by restricting the
data in the form of a list
now let's learn about pivot charts and
tables which is one more very useful
feature of excel and which allows you to
work with your data or perform data
analysis
now pivot table is a summary of your
data
it is used in cases where there are
numerous rows and columns in your data
set
and it allows you to group your data in
several ways so that you can derive
meaningful information from it now the
visual representation of a pivot table
is termed as a pivot chart now how do we
do that so let's see an example now here
is some data here you see we have some
row labels which basically gives me some
category of
items here it also tells me the sum of
sales
and basically it gives me per item what
is the total sum of sales which were
made now how do i get this here so for
example if i would want to delete this
and i would be interested in getting the
total sales under each category of items
now we know that we have
different data here and it's huge for
example on the
row end if i just do a control and right
arrow it tells me what's my right last
column
and if i just do a control and down
arrow it tells me there are
9994 rows
now i can use this
and what i can do is i can basically
work on
insert and go to pivot table now this
basically tells you need to choose the
range now since i have chosen my first
row and first column it basically has
selected the data and that's fine now do
you want the result in a new worksheet
i'll say existing worksheet and i can
choose a location now that basically
needs me to select a field might be we
can just select this field
and that should be good enough
so
for example if i close this or if i say
okay
so
this is basically an indication that my
pivot table
will be created now what are the fields
we are interested in so as per the
problem we need to find out what the
total sales for each category so let's
go in here and let's select the field
category now as soon as you do that it
shows that
the rows
which are
being selected are for this column
category and now we are interested in
getting the sales so we would want the
sales per category so let's select this
so you see sum of sales is selected now
close this and that's it that's that's
your data so it shows you row labels
it tells you what are the different
categories
and it also gives you
sum of sales which is per category now
this is
one easy example where we have solved
the problem where we have tried to find
what were the total sales under each
category of items so for example let's
have
another data set so again you can just
check how many rows we have and it is
basically the same 9994
and if i look in columns it basically
shows me profit is the last column
and
here
we would want to find out
which category
so for example let me get rid this
with subcategory of items sold the
maximum under each category so
we have some categories here which says
furniture and it shows some sub
categories
and then it shows me office supplies and
then some sub categories and same thing
with technology now we know how we got
this data but this is different than
what we were seeing here so here we were
just getting the categories but but we
did not have any breakdown
of sub categories within this particular
category and here you see there is a
breakdown and then basically you can
also apply a filter which basically says
what is the data you want and if you are
interested in finding out a particular
value now how do we do this so for
example let me get rid of this now we
know how we can find out the category of
items but we would want to find out
which sub category of items sold the
maximum under each category so here we
are not looking at sales but we are
looking at the quantity
okay
so what we can do is we can go to
the first row and first column
click on insert click on pivot table
data is already selected let's choose
existing worksheet let's choose a
location in our worksheet where we would
want to have this so might be i can
select this particular field and then
just close this
so it says this is the existing
worksheet say okay and now you need to
select your
columns
so for example
if
i would want the data for categories so
i can select this now i know that within
category these are the options which we
have and then there is a sub category so
let's select that and if you see here
now we have the data which will be
filtered so based on your category and
sub category and then we will choose
quantity so it automatically understands
that this is something on which
summation can be done so let's select
this and close on this now if you see
here we have got our items
where we can see
the sub categories within a particular
category now i can basically close this
and that just shows me
high level categories here
so here
i can
again
select a particular
row and column i can go for
either a new pivot table so we could
basically select this the row is already
selected
existing worksheet is what i want so now
i will select
this particular place
say okay now we do the same thing like
what we did earlier
so we will select category subcategory
and quantity so the data has already
come in
just select this and now you already
have all your data but this is not what
we want we want to basically apply a
filter
to this now how do we do that so we can
go for
slicer so i can go for insert slicer and
then it tells
what are
the sub categories which you are
interested in so for example
if i go for something like
subcategory and say okay
so this tells me what are the categories
you are interested in so for example we
know that furniture has furnishings with
the highest value so i can select say
furnishings
and then
i was interested in office supplies
so within office supply i can basically
search for
here
binder so i can just do a control and
select binder
and then i can also know for technology
i can select phones so i'll say control
and select phones
and now if you see the filter has been
applied
and we have these subcategories which
are selected so we have our data here
now we don't need really this so i can
just delete this
and i have my data which shows me
furniture being the main category and
that has only furnishings office supply
having binders and technology having
phones and that basically
is a filter applied on the result of
your pivot so this is how we are seeing
with sub category of items were sold
maximum for each category
so this is how you can easily use pivot
tables and you can do some analysis
let's look at some more
examples now
let's see if you have to answer this
question which says which were the top
three states for each region
that made the highest average profit
now how do we calculate that
so for example this is the data we have
and as i have instructed earlier you can
select the first row and first column
you can click on insert go into pivot
table
and that basically selects all your data
we will choose the result should be in
this existing worksheet so select this
click here
and then basically
let's
select
this cell
and
i will say okay so now my pivot table
will be here so we are interested in
finding out top three states within each
region which have made the highest
profit or which have made the highest
average profit so for that first we will
select
region so when we select region it shows
here region and within region you will
then select state so
within every region you have multiple
states so that's what we are selecting
and then we are interested in looking at
the profit so let's select profit and
that automatically shows up here so we
can now say close this
so basically we have all the data but we
are looking at the sum of profit but
that's not what we want
we are looking for
top three states
from each region that made the highest
average profit now how do we change that
so here we have sum of profit so i can
do a right click and basically i can say
summarize values by average so now i'm
getting the average here and that
basically tells per region
i have the average profit
but first is let's sort this data so
let's go into sort more options and here
i have average of profit
or for example as i said you can select
region say okay
and now it is
basically having the
regions
and then you have your state value so
again we can do a sorting here and i can
say
let's go for more sort options i'll say
descending
the state values should be based on
average profit
so let's say okay and now if you see
in particular region we have
the data which has been
sorted
wherein you have the highest average
profit on the top
now what we can also do is we can
basically
then go for filtering we can say top 10
but i'm not interested in top 10 so i
could reduce this to top three
and this is the items average of profit
say okay and now you see per region
you have
the data which is
showing me top three states what are the
average and then you are also looking at
the subtotal so which basically says
average profit for your west now if you
would want to arrange this
your west and south and east and central
in a particular alphabetical order if
you would want to sort it you can always
do a sorting and you can choose sort z
to a
if that's what you would want to do or
you can go for
sorting
more sort options
and you want to sort the region which is
as of now
based on descending z2a let's make it
ascending say okay
and now you see the data has been
filtered so it says per region
now you can always select this and you
can say what is this so this is
basically your average of profit
now
we are looking at
each region and the states the top three
states as we wanted
within the region and what is the
average
now we have one more question what is
the percentage contribution of each
sub-category of products under each
category to the total sales so we know
there are different products
there are different categories and
all the categories contribute to the
total sales so we would want to find out
what is the percentage contribution of
each subcategory
of products
under each category so we not only want
the
category percentage but we would also
want what is the contribution of each
subcategory
to
each category to the total sales how do
we do that so for that we need to again
just place
our cursor here or select the first row
and first column click on your insert
click on your pivot table and now the
data is already selected existing
worksheet
place your cursor here
and then let's select this
cell say okay
now your pivot table fields are here so
we are interested in category
so let's select category
and then within a category we will have
sub categories and we are interested in
the sales data wherein it is already
going to give us the sum of sales but we
would want this
in the form of percentage rather than
just the sum now we can click here value
field settings and it says if you would
want to summarize this it says show
value as
and
what are the values you would want so
you can straight away go ahead here and
say percentage of grand total so we
could do that because we know
we will get a sum of sales and grand
total now i could basically say
in the percentage of grand total say
okay
and then
just close this
so once you have closed this you see
already the data is in
percentage so now we have our data with
sub categories but we also want the data
to be sorted might be in a descending
order which tells which subcategory is
contributing more than others we can
select how many sub categories we are
interested in so we can basically select
one of the sub category cells
right click now you have option filter
and you have sorting so we can say more
sort options
now here i will say descending and
you want the
descending to be sum of sales which is
already showing as percentage
click on ok and now you see for each
category
it shows the percentage contribution
towards the sales
it shows the sub categories contribution
to a particular category and also to
total sales
so
technically speaking if you look at all
these values which are sub categories
and if you would total them that would
be your total grand total so this is how
we can solve a simple problem like this
what is the percentage contribution of
each subcategory of products under
each category to the total sales
the next question is which customer made
the lowest profit in the home office
segment in each state now here we know
that we are looking for
home office segment
we are looking for customer which made
the lowest profit
we are also looking for the state
as the main
criteria so
in each state
we would look for home office segment
and within that we would look for
customer which has made the lowest
profit that means
the lowest value
of the profit so how do we do this so
let's say let's get into
selecting our row and column we will go
into insert i'll say pivot table
i'll say existing worksheet
and let me get my result here so let's
say okay now that gives me the pivot
table so the first thing is we are
looking at
per
state
and
i would be interested in
[Music]
home office segment or i could first
start with segment now here we have
segment
and in segment i can basically select
home office so i can just do a uncheck
and select home office only
and now i can select
state so that will be my
sub category within segment and then
within state
we would want to find out the customer
so let's get the customer name
and we are interested in finding out the
lowest profit so let's select profit
and here we have sum of profits so the
fields are selected close this
and now you have your data
which basically shows me
the names of customers which made the
profit but it's
it's not sorted so we can sort this
and we have state entries also so that's
fine so what i can do is here
i can basically say sorting go to more
sort options i can say i want to do a
descending or i want to do an ascending
and ascending based on
sum of profit so let's do that now you
see
the topmost value is the lowest value
per state
within home office segment now what we
also want is we just want one value per
state
so how do we do that so we can just
go for filtering go for top 10 values
i'm interested in bottom value and in
that also
i'm looking for only the
lowest value so let's select one
say okay and now you see we have data
for home office segment
per state
customer who has made the lowest profit
so we have easily answered this question
using our pivot table
now say for example we have a question
which says find the sales made in each
quarter of 2016 for all the regions
so the data has to be divided quarterly
and use order year as a slicer we can do
that by selecting what data we would
want to slice
and then we would want to create a pivot
chart also so for example how do we do
that
so for example
i will get rid of this
i will get rid of
this my pivot chart which we can
recreate
so find the sales made in each quarter
of 2016 for all the regions
so this is what we want now how do we do
this
so for example let's select this
we will do a insert pivot table we will
basically say existing worksheet
and then i can select this particular
cell i'll say okay
and now
i'm interested in data quarterly so
first let's select
our field here
so we should basically have
if all our fields are selected say for
example if i say order date
now
you see we have quarters and ears which
are selected
now we could be selecting these fields
which says
quarters years
and if i would want data to be filtered
based on years i could do that or i
could get rid of here so i have quarters
i have order date
so
that's being already selected now what
else we need we need to find out
for every region so let's select the
region
and we can also add region as a column
here so that will basically give me all
the regions
as different columns
and then finally we want the sales so
let's select this
and now let's look what we have
so if you see here
we have our data
which is
for each quarter
it gives me the total data but what we
would be interested in is not looking at
the total data but we are only
interested in quarter of
2016. now how do we do that so what we
do here is we have row labels
so let's click on this so we have date
filters
and then in date filters we can go for
between and then we will say
2016
and the value has to be 1
and then let's select this
and let's change this to 2016
and
this is 12th month
and then we can say 31.
so we are saying the date has to be 2016
and it basically says not a valid date
so let's select
let's select a particular date and see
so the month has to be here
so let's see in this
and let's make it date
and say okay
and now we have our data which is
for
2016.
so for example i could basically select
this
and here i could be
looking at
what are the filters we have so it says
clear filter from order data so we have
applied the filter on order date
and
these are your date filters which is
basically
date 16 oh this is wrong so this one has
to be changed to 2016.
so select this and now we have our data
for
2016.
so we have found the sales made in each
quarter of 2016 for all the regions the
grand total
for a particular quarter if we are
looking at the value
or for individual months in a particular
quarter
and we have sliced the data now we could
have also
introduced a slicer by
selecting
which field we would want to implement
so for example if i would select a
particular field and then i could click
on slicer i could choose i would want to
slice the date based on order date and
then could have done it or we have just
given the
date for 2016. now we just need to
plot a graph for this and that's very
easy so you just need to select
the complete pivot data and here you
have the chart options so let's go for
line chart
and that basically shows me the line
chart so we can select this
we can just drag and drop it here
and then
we can basically check if that is
showing us the data so if you see here
this is line chart where it has divided
the regions in different colors
so we have all the regions we could
filter out in pivot chart a particular
region
we have the quarterly
time here in order data the filter is
applied it says it is 2016.
in quarters it tells me it is 16. so we
have our data we have created a pivot
chart and basically we have sliced the
data for
2016.
let's answer one more question and
that's finding the profit made in each
year
for all the categories of products
in east and west regions only and then
we would want to create a histogram
for the same pivot table so histogram
usually gives us the frequencies so
let's look at how do we calculate the
profit made in each year for all the
categories so what i can do is
i can basically
select my
row id here and now i'll do a pivot
table
so the data is already selected i'll
choose existing worksheet let's select
this particular cell say okay
now what are we interested in now if you
look at the fields we don't see any
years or quarters and so on so for
example here i can just choose order
date
and then basically
i can choose say for example
years or quarters
the data which is coming out from my
order date so here i will just select
years
now
then i have my order date
so
we are interested in the years
orders and
we are interested in
let's look at our column or the question
what we had here
so we have years
find the profit made in each year so
let's select
profit so that basically says sum of
profit but then
i'm on also interested in
for all the categories of products so
what i can do is here
i have my field which is category and
that i'll add to the columns so that
shows me what are the different
categories
and this looks fine now i'm also
interested in east and west regions so
that is basically in the region so
either we could add a slicer or we could
do a filtering here by adding the
filters so first is i'll click on region
and here it says select all i'm only
interested in east and west
so let's select this
take this
put it here let's say okay and now
we have the data which has been filtered
based on the region so here we have
region so you can always look at the
filter it is east and west
and we have our year data
per year we have
different categories you can always look
at what are these column labels so this
is my different categories
and this is the profit per category
and then you have your grand total so we
have already our data now let's say
close this
so we have our data for all these years
different categories the profits made
per year
and if i would want i could go into an
year and i could look into different
months so that also
is showing up and now we would want to
basically plot a histogram with this
data so i can just
place my cursor here i can select this
and then i can go into insert and here i
have different options so we can go for
bar chart
we can go for insert hierarchy chart
we can go into waterfall funnel stock
surface or radar chart so there are
different options what you have here and
we will go for a simple histogram which
is two dimensional
let's select this
and here you see you can obviously
select different regions
you have your years which shows up
you have your order date
and then you have your categories which
can be chosen for your histogram or for
your bar chart and that basically is how
you use your pivot table you use some
calculations and then you can plot your
needed graph to visualize the data
and understand it in a better way hi
everyone
welcome to this tutorial on microsoft
excel let's look at an example of
one more useful function in excel and
that is vlookup
now vlookup is used to see if a value
exists in a range of values and we can
create a range of values which is
nothing but
a block of cells which has a name and
can be referenced so
mainly to use vlookup we need to create
a named range
and that can be referenced anywhere in
the workbook or the other option is you
can always drag and select
uh the range of data in which you would
want to search something now there is
also
other functions such as hlookup which
pretty much does the same thing however
it does it horizontally that is left to
right instead of vertically there are
other functions like lookup and x lookup
and so on so when we talk about vlookup
let's see how we do that so for example
this is the range of or this is the data
which has been given to you and here is
the question find the employee name with
employee id 107. now assume that you
might have huge amount of data and you
may want to search something so how do
we do it now here i have created some
column and then some basic formatting i
have given it as an employee id i've
given employee name now what i can do is
i can create a range of data now how do
i do that or a named range so what you
can do is you can select the data and
then you can do a right click now here
you have something like get data from
table range so you can do that you can
define a name so you can click on this
and here
you can give a
name to the range what you would want to
call it so for example let's say
our search
now that's the named range i'm creating
and just say okay so the scope is
workbook and i have created a named
range which you can see here so it shows
for search our search so you have
created a named range now how do we do a
vlookup here so for that we can use a
formula so for example i would want to
search for employee name where employee
id is whatever you would want to search
for
so employee id we can give here 107. now
that's what we would want to search the
employee name for
and employee name is what we are
interested now what we can do is we can
use the function
option here i can do a insert function
and that shows me different functions
which are here now vlookup is showing up
because i have recently searched for it
or you can
basically just type in here look
and you can do a go so that shows you
all the lookup options what you have
like look up hlookup match vlookup and
so on so we would be interested in
vlookup so let's select that and click
on ok
now that basically opens up this
function arguments and it shows what
does this function do so it says looks
for a value in the leftmost column of a
table
and then returns a value in the same row
from a column you specify
by default the table must be sorted in
an ascending order now you can
basically say this is what you would
want to search for what is the lookup
value if you place your cursor here it
says what is the table array that is
nothing but the range which we can use
our named range here we have the column
index number which basically tells me
what is the column number in the range
which we want so what is the value we
want from which column and then
basically you have range lookup which
basically is the fourth
option
and range lookup is nothing but
it can have two values so true or false
so true basically means closest match
and then false should be an exact match
so let's do that so for lookup value we
would want to
give a particular value
which is nothing but
we would be interested in say employee
name
so i can
basically
search for a value based on the lookup
value now how do we do it so we are
saying we would want to search for
employee id which is 107. so what i can
do is i can select this
cell here which tells that this is the
value
or employee id for which i would want to
search the employee name i could
actually select the cell here which is h
so that whatever value you feed in here
you can search for that value so might
be we can select this one which is h6
and whatever value we key in here we
will be searching for employee name for
that employee id
now table array is we would want to give
a range so what we can do is we can give
our range so for example we had selected
something like our search
and if you see here that already selects
or shows me employee id employee name
email address so it gives me the range
now
column index number so which
column are we interested in that means
what is the value we are searching for
so we are searching for employee name
which is the second column so i can just
say 2
and that basically is the column number
and then you have to give a range lookup
which is a logical value so either you
give an exact match or
you can basically give a
closest match so we can say for example
do a zero which basically means false or
you can say one which is true so let's
go for zero now that's our formula so it
says vlookup you will search for the
value as per h6
in the range
and then you are looking for employee
name which is column number two and then
true or false so let's click on ok and
that basically gives me the value which
is
parallel birch
so here i am searching for employee name
and you can basically drag this
for other columns and you can do that so
if it finds
employee
id here now say for example if we had an
employee id somebody enters an employee
id which is not in the range for example
let's try
121 and then you see this is basically
an error
right because
it does not have any employee id with
121. now how do i take care of this so
there is a formula which is called if
error and that can be used to take care
of this
so if the value is not found then it
will
show whatever i would want to
show here so what i can do is i can
still select this
and what i can do is i can search in
function
say for example this is the function we
are looking at but what we can do is
we can test it here so for example if i
look in function and if i search for
error and say oh
go so there are lots of
functions here and this is the function
we are interested in if error so if i
say ok now this takes the value and what
is the value if error so for value what
i can do is basically
i can select
the value from here which is nothing but
our vlookup formula
and value if error so for example i will
basically say for example not found so
we can try this and we can say okay now
here it says not found so whenever it is
n a it is not found
now
if we look at the formula here it says
if error it takes the value of h7 which
is nothing but our vlookup and then it
is
showing us the value which we have
entered so for example if i would say 1
107
like earlier and then hit on enter so it
says panel of cruise and it shows us the
value
right and if we enter something else
then basically here it shows any and it
shows not found but what we want to do
is we want to merge these two so what i
can do is i can get rid of
or i can basically take this one
now
what i would want is i want this formula
to
be here
so what i can do is i can say if error
and then
basically
given your vlookup
option or function here and then say for
example not found here
not found
now that basically will take care of any
kind of error if the value is not found
so when we say 121 it basically says not
found but if i say 107 which is found
then it shows me the value so we are
using vlookup but then we are also using
if error which will take care of our
error message
or basically the not applicable
pound not applicable to replaced with
whatever value we key in
similarly we can do the same thing here
so we have the find the job title so we
are interested in finding out the job
title once the employee name is given
now employee name can basically have a
value from the cell or whatever value
you would want to key in
how do we do it so we basically start
with
our v lookup so that's the
function we are interested in
so you can just do a double click now
you are interested in finding out the
value whichever is given here
so that's the lookup value
and then you are interested in
finding out the job title from the range
so i will still give our range which
basically
also shows for example let's do a
double click here and that basically
selects the range and now i'm interested
in finding out the job title so that's
column number
four
and then i can just give zero which is
for false
so now we have given our vlookup but
that shows not applicable because we
have not given any employee name so we
can key in the value here which says
fred stone and now
if we are basically giving the value so
fred stone now
we will have to search if there is any
job title which is fred stone so here is
the value so that should be showing up
let's check what has gone wrong so we
are giving our range
we are
interested in
finding out the value but what the
mistake what we did here was
that when we want to search for a value
say for example let's take this vlookup
and let's replace this value of h12 with
the
value here so fredstone
and then basically
we will give our range we will save
which is the column we are interested in
and then give true or false
so
we can also basically take care of this
error message so for example let's take
this
complete formula from here
and just
just copy this formula
and now we can put in here the formula
but then this is where we were searching
for h6 which was employee id
now that's not what we are interested in
we are interested in finding out the
value
so let's take this one and replace this
with
the value given here
and then i give my range i say which is
the column i'm interested in so i'm
interested in looking for job title and
then let's search so it basically tells
me
not found so let's check this
now the error which we were facing was
because when we talk about your vlookup
let's look at the formula again and here
say for example
i go for function
and then i select vlookup and say for
example i say okay
now just look at the description here
looks for a value in the left most
column of a table
now earlier the range which we had
selected had the left most column as
employee id and that's why it was giving
an error so how do we fix that so for
example
let's
basically
remove this function from here
now what we want to do is we would want
to search for the stock broker now if
you see here
i have given a range which is b
1 to d 21
so we would want
the value for what we would want to
search say employee name that should be
the leftmost column so
so that's how
we have our function so let's do that so
say for example the name is given here
so we want a range so either we can
create a range like earlier by selecting
say for example this data
now am i interested in salary no i'm
interested in job title right so i can
basically just select these three
columns
and then i can define a name so i can
say our
search
to
and let's give a named range and that's
only because we would want to easily
reference or use that named
search or name range now here we would
want to use vlookup but we would also do
an if error
now within that we can say
v
lookup
and then you need to
select what is the value what your
function takes
so basically this is my function we will
say if the value is not found
then we will give this so you can create
an external structure
and then within your vlookup we will say
the leftmost column which we are
interested in so
that's your employee name
so in employee name we have the value so
either i can directly select the value
here in the column b or i will give the
value whichever is fed in here the
employee name
then i need to give a range so let's
select our range so that's your hour
search too
and then you need to select the column
number
so we are interested in finding out the
job title so that's the third column so
let's say three and then just give it 0
and then hit on enter so it says not
found because you have not given any
employee name now
let's
try to find the job title of fred stone
so i can just select or i can say equal
and then i can just given a value and
that basically shows me the job title so
this is how you use vlookup
we have also used if error which
basically takes care of error message if
the value is not found so for example we
can test this
here we have fred stone
so for example if i
just empty this and i point it to
something which does not exist so that
shows me not found or if you just select
this and then key in a value it shows
you this might be we can just type in so
if i say fred
then basically it says not found because
we are looking for exact match now if we
had changed this to the closest match
something like this then it would have
tried to find something but then we
don't have anything which is just with
this
so there are different ways of doing it
so what we can do is we can always go
for the exact match
and that's basically the value
and here we can basically key in any
value for example i would be interested
in finding out
this one
and let's give this so you can search in
this way so you can also have statements
which can be searching one related to
other
now here the question was to find the
job title of fred stone so let's type in
fred stone and that basically shows me
the job title which we are interested in
so let's search for
job title let's go for exact match and
then search so it is stock broker so if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
now that we have looked at vlookup it
would be interesting to see how
horizontal lookup or edge lookup works
it basically works in the on the same
lines but here
instead of
vertically searching through the columns
the range is more of horizontally
defined so we search
in rows rather than in columns so for
example this is the data which has been
given to you and you have various
columns so you have employee id you have
your employee name
you have employee email address
you basically have the job title
of different employees
and then basically you have the salary
so this is the data which has been given
to you
and you are asked to search or you are
interested in finding out say the salary
based on employee name or job title
based on employee id so what we need to
do is we need to define the range here
now range can depend on what you are
searching for so for example when i am
searching employee name and salary so i
am interested in these four rows when
i'm saying employee id and job title
then might be this is the range and i
don't need salary so i can create a
named range if we are interested in so
that we can easily search for it or we
can straight away give
the
the first cell value which is basically
a one here
and then the last
value here which is g and then you can
give 5 so you can do that or you can
create a named range whichever way you
would want to do it so for example we
would want to create a named range for
our first question which is
find the salary of eden connell using h
lookup so we are interested in this so
let's select
these four rows all the way for your
columns now
like we did earlier we can just define a
name might be we can call it our search
three
and we can just give okay so that's the
named range which we have created
now what we would want is we want to
search for the salary based on employee
name
so here we can insert our function so
let's look up
and let's search for look
and just click on go so here you have h
lookup and basically that's the function
i'm interested in say okay
so this says what is the lookup value
which you are interested in so we are
interested in finding out the value
based on the employee name
so for example let's select this cell
that gives us more dynamism and you can
add in any name and you can search for
the salary
or you can basically give the employee
name exactly from the employee name
value here which is d
two so we can give eden conal from here
so let's select this now table array so
we need to give our range so let's say
our search three
then you need to give the row index
number now this is different than
vlookup in vlookup you have column index
number and here you have row index
number so what are you interested in
searching for so we are interested in
searching for salary now in our range
that is basically the fourth row
remember we created a range from
employee name to salary so let's give
the row index number which is 4
and the range lookup will say 0 which is
basically exact match and that completes
our formula so click on ok and that
basically gives me the salary for edin
connell
now that's basically because we have fed
in the value here
and that is basically giving me this
so i can again
do if error if i would be interested in
to basically take care of error message
if the value is not found for that you
can look into the previous example which
is vlookup now similarly we are
interested in finding out the job title
for employee id 1 0 5 how do we do that
so we need to use edge lookup
well we could have done with vlookup but
here the data is more arranged in the
form of rows
so how do we do that so we can again use
hlookup but and we can give a range
or named range or let's for this time
let's basically
key in our range manually so we can do
that so let's go for h lookup
now what do we want to search for so we
will say this is the value
then we need to give a range
now as i said if you would want to give
a range manually so for example i'll say
a
and then i'll say a
1
colon and then i'm interested in
g
and then the row will be 4 so salary row
is not what we are we are not interested
in so let's say g
and then we can give 4 so that basically
gives me the range
right instead of having a named range so
we can do that and then we need to give
the row index number so we are
interested in finding out the job title
which is basically in our range the
fourth row and then give zero for true
or false so if you see here it tells if
it is one it is approximate match
false is an exact match and we can close
this bracket that completes our formula
it takes the value which is given in
employee id and then it will try to
search for the job title so that
basically shows wherever the employee id
is 105 the job title is fabricator again
you can use if error
wherein
your if error can then be working on
hlookup and can take care of error so
that if an employee id is keyed in
for which there is no matching value
then
it will
not show you
a not applicable error in
instead of that it will replace with the
word whatever you have specified so in
this way you can easily use hlookup to
search
from the range of data which is
horizontally arranged and in the
previous example we were seeing how you
use
vlookup when the data is arranged
vertically
so we have looked at
vlookup and hlookup and what we have
seen is vlookup has a limitation in one
way that
we need to basically give a range where
the leftmost column is the one which is
used now instead of that we might be
interested in searching in specific
columns and not all the columns well
that can also affect the time taken to
search for the data
wherein we can select particular columns
or particular ranges rather than
selecting all the data which has to be
searched for so for example we have this
question find the salary of hank
saunders
now that's the employee name which we
have here and we would want to find out
the salary so what are the columns we
are interested in so one is your
employee name and one is your salary and
these are the only two columns which we
are interested in so instead of using
vlookup now like i've shown earlier you
can create a named range for these two
columns and you can use that
or we can manually give the range here
so let's go for lookup function here and
lookup function will basically help us
in searching what we are interested in
so we are interested in finding out the
employee name
and we are interested in finding out the
salary based on the employee name so how
do we do that so here in lookup i can
first give the value which is here
employee name now
whatever
employee name is keyed in here we will
be searching for salary of that employee
now lookup function needs a lookup value
so
we are searching
based on employee name then it says
lookup vector so we will basically then
say
what is going to be our lookup vector so
here we need to give a range so what are
we interested in we are interested in
finding out the salary based on employee
name so first goes our range
based on which we need to search so
that's your employee name so let's for
example
select this one so that's our range b1
to b21
so that will basically have the employee
name in which we will be searching for
and then we are interested in searching
out the the result vector that is
basically the column from which we want
the value that's our salary column so
let's select this
and that completes our lookup function
so now if you hit on enter it shows
that for this employee where the name is
hunk saunders the salary is 5400
now you can test it by
basically giving some other name
so for example if i replace this with
say
fred stone
and that basically shows me the value
for fred stone we can replace it to the
question which we have that is hank
saunders and that shows me the salary so
that's a simple example of lookup which
allows you to search by selecting a
range of columns rather than having the
leftmost column which has to be
referenced similarly we have one more
question find the employee id
of
this particular email id so we need to
again use our lookup function so we'll
say lookup now what are we interested in
we will search based on this email
address so i will select this
then i need to give
that
based on email address we are searching
the employee id so email address is in
this column so let's select this range
and then we are interested in employee
id so then goes
our result vector so select this column
and that basically completes your
formula so close this bracket and hit on
enter so that basically shows me the
employee id for an employee with this
email address so this is how you use
lookup now as i've explained earlier you
can be using the if error and you can
basically see how
your index match can be used now here is
an example of if error
so basically this shows how if error
helps so say for example as i showed in
your sheet 1 so check for employee james
bond if the value is not present display
not found and what are we doing we are
basically nesting our vlookup
inside if error with a not found option
which basically says if the value given
in the cell h
is not found then basically
it will
display not found so here you also
notice that the range which has been
given has been selected that is b1 to
c21 now we could have used a named range
which basically helps us in searching
for multiple functions
we are searching for 2 that is the
column number 2 here that is employee
name so check for employee james bond if
the value is not present or no so we are
basically just searching for employee
name
here and then give your 0 or 1. so
that's basically usage of your if error
which i've shown earlier and the same
thing can be applied for your edge
lookup also
now suppose you have been given some
additional questions for example you
know instead of using your vlookup or
hlookup or lookup examples what we have
seen
say for example you are asked to find
the salary of peter daniels now we
already know how to find that using
vlookup right so for example we want to
find out the salary for this employee
name which is peter daniels i can use a
vlookup
however sometimes we may also want to
use a index match an index match is also
one useful function to do that so we can
basically search based on that so we
have to define the range
of data we have to then say what do we
want to match so that's basically an
employee name
and then we are interested in finding
out
say for example
based on the range
of
employees you would want to find out
the value of salary so we are then
giving a range and doing it how do we do
that so for example here
i can use a function which is called
index
and if you see here it says returns a
value or reference
of the cell
at the intersection of a particular row
and column in a given range so this is
where index function can be useful now
we can start with this function it says
it needs an array that's nothing but a
range so we can basically select all our
data so i can say a1
all the way to e21 so that basically is
my range
now i would want to find the salary of
this employee name which is peter
daniels so i can use internally here
basically you need to give a row number
so what we can do is we can do a match
so we can use an internal function match
now we need to basically
give it correctly so we need to say
match
now how does this match function work so
we need to basically match for a value
so for example we'll select whatever
employee name is given here so that's
peter daniels now that's basically what
we would want to match
now where do we want to match this so we
want to match in the column b which has
employee
names so we can give a range which is b1
to be
21 so that's basically
within the employee names we are looking
for a match
which is given here that's in h6
and
we want to do a match so we want to do a
exact match so let's do a comma zero
and then we are interested in finding
out the salary
based on this match and salary is in our
fifth column so let's basically give the
column number here and then just close
this bracket
so that basically
completes your function and just hit on
enter so that shows me the salary of
peter daniels right so this is an easy
way when you can use the index function
remember first you give the range
and then you need to give your matching
condition so when you say match i would
take the value whatever is given in this
cell
i will search in the range of values
which is employee names
i will find an exact match and what i'm
interested in is finding the salary for
peter daniels now similarly say for
example you have been given a question
find the employee id with salary 10 000.
so you want to find out the employee id
wherever the salary is 10 000. so we are
obviously looking for an exact match now
how do we do that so we can start with
our index function and within index
function we need to give a range
so for example i am interested in
finding out
say for example
our range which is a 1
2
e 21 so that's what i'm interested in or
you are actually interested in searching
based on
say your
salary so you are interested in
searching the employee id so maybe if i
just do a 821 let's see what happens
here
now then i can just do a match
so match will be now done based on the
value which is here h
13
so i will do a match for this one now i
need to give a range
so let's
basically give a range which will be we
are interested in
searching employee id based on the
salary column so that's your e column so
i will say e1 to
21 that's what i'm interested in
searching
finding a match for this salary we want
an exact match so first let's close this
one now
that's fine i mean we are interested in
finding out the employee id
based on the match which is within this
range
and
then what we would want to do is we
would want to
basically find the employee id employee
id is in my
column a so what i can do is i can
additionally give a match here
and then i can say i'm interested in the
finding out the value for employee id
and that basically needs a range so the
range here will be just the
the column headings so we will give a1
all the way to e1 so that's the range in
which we would want to search and we
would want to find a match for employee
id
we want an exact match so let's close
this one and that basically closes my
match and we need to close our index
function so now that shows me employee
id
where the salary is 10 000.
so this is how you can do your index
matches where you can give a range
then you can say what you need to match
within which particular column
whether it is an exact match or
approximate match and then the column
from where you are interested in finding
out the value so same thing we did here
we basically gave a complete range and
if you closely see
we were only interested in finding out
the employee id so here i gave a range
a1 to a21 which is basically this
particular column so that's where we are
interested in finding out
match basically will give your lookup
value so that's h13
then we gave a range which is salary
that's what we are interested in
and then we said when we are doing a
match we are only interested in finding
out the employee id
which is in a range of column names and
then doing an exact match
so this is how you can use index match
instead of lookup which can also give
you
some exceptions and searching for
specific columns or specific rows now if
error we have already discussed where
you nest your vlookup or h lookup inside
it
so this is how you can use your lookup
functions hlookup
vlookup lookup or index match to search
for data
some function like this which shows up
xln dot x lookup
and then you're trying to search for
something so don't be
surprised with that so xln is basically
a prefix added to functions that don't
exist in the version of excel you are
using
you have excel 2013 and say your friend
has a new version of excel say office
365
or excel 2016
and basically he uses your new cool
function and sends the file to you so
that's where
you will have this xln prefix as i'm
showing up here so for example what is
the job title of xavier power is what
you would want to search and here the
function which shows up xl and x lookup
and then you are searching so this is
basically
something which is the function now if i
just select what it has selected here
and if i hit on enter it shows that this
does not work in my excel here and
that's because of the version but what i
can do is i can fix this by removing
this
details here
and that basically shows lookup we are
searching for
job title based on employee name which
is in this field h6
and then we need to give a range so we
need to give a range of names employee
name
and then basically
the
job title range which is basically the
job title so now if i just hit on enter
it gives me the value so it's as simple
as that similarly here what is the
employee id of the person with this
email we have already looked at the
lookup function so if it shows your xlnx
lookup all you need to do is remove this
and then keep the lookup function
searching for the value
based on the range of values and then
searching for a value within a range of
values so just hit on enter and that
gives you the value and same thing goes
for this job title so what is the job
title and salary of employee name
so we have this function now what i can
do is
here i am interested in finding out the
value for this particular function how
do i fix this
i can basically select this
and then just do a lookup
based on the values and
it basically says you can't change part
of an array so we can fix this now what
we need to do is we need to basically
search based on
this particular value so we will
basically say i want to do a lookup
now lookup should be based on employee
name whatever name is given here
then you need to find the job title in
salary so for job title i want to find
based on employee name so i will give a
range
and then basically i will say i'm
interested in finding out the job title
so i will give a different range
and then basically close this so
that basically shows
now this is basically because of the
function which we have here so basically
to fix this what we will have to do is
we will have to delete all the columns
here which were selected such as
employee name job title and salary
because that was giving you
an error you cannot delete a part of an
array now what we want to do is we want
to find the job title and salary based
on the employee name so we can do that
using lookup as we have done earlier so
we will use a lookup function now what
we are interested in finding out is the
job title based on employee name so we
can select this cell which does not have
any value
then we need to basically say from which
range or based on what you want to
search so we want to search based on
employee name
and we want to find out the job title so
we can basically give a range of values
and then
we will be interested in finding out the
job title
so let's select the job title range and
that basically completes our lookup so
let's close this and hit on enter now it
says obviously error because this does
not have any value
we will fix that by giving in a value
here
same thing we can do for salary so for
example i can just drag and drop it here
and in this one
instead of
basically having a range which is your
we will be interested in finding out the
salary so
let's see what is the range we give
so the range should be employee name
so we will basically select employee
name as the range
and then
we are interested in finding out the
salary so we will select this particular
range and what we are interested in
finding out is basically
employee name
or
we are interested in finding out based
on employee name so let's select
this particular column and then hit or
enter so both of these are any values
now just feed in an employee name so we
will say for example eduardo and that
basically gives me the job title and
salary so that's how you can fix
your
excel fn
error
so same thing goes here so it shows you
xln is what you would want to search
might be if you don't find something you
would want to
push in name not found so first is we
will have to fix this part so we will
have to remove this because that's not
supported in my excel and then i have
lookup i'm searching based on h24
which is basically employee id you're
giving a range which is a2 to 821
because we would want to find
name not found
for
a particular employee id so i'm giving a
range which is a2 to a21
i'm trying to search for the name which
is from b2 to b21 and then i'm giving
name not found so
say for example we can do this lookup
but then
with lookup you don't have this direct
option what we can do is we can use if
error
if error
and then basically try to search so that
gives your lookup value
and then you will have to close this one
and then again if it gives you some
error like this we can obviously go for
vlookup and fix this so here
we are searching for a particular range
and then let's search for this value
and basically to fix this what i did was
i just use a vlookup so we know that
employee id 121 does not exist so i'm
just using if error i'm doing a vlookup
where i'm searching for the value given
in h 19
and then
i am saying
that i would want to search from a range
which is basically b1 to c21 that is in
employee name and say
email address for example
and we would want to basically search
for
name not found so we can
instead of giving b21 or b1 to c21 we
can restrict it to just b1 to b21
we are searching in column two we are
searching for exact value and if it does
not find then it says name not found and
that's how we do it so we can always
replace and fix this excel fn
errors
if you
are
using
uh some spreadsheet which was or excel
which was sent by
um someone else who is using a different
version so in this way we can use your
tickum different lookup functions
take care of your errors use a index
match welcome to this tutorial on
microsoft excel
let's quickly see
some more
examples of doing data analysis using
excel and for that we can
use
some inbuilt add-ins which can be added
to our excel sheet so for example if you
would want to do a descriptive analytics
or descriptive analysis on your data say
for example getting your descriptive
statistics such as your mean median mode
and so on so we can do that and we can
use excel for it so for example you can
if you are given some data say i have
temperature price of ice cream units
sold and i would want to have
descriptive statistics on this what i
can do is i can click on file
and here in file you can click on
options and within options click on
add-ins
now within add-ins you have excel
add-ins which is selected here so click
on say go for example and that shows
what add-ins are available and you can
choose which ones are you interested in
so for example i have chosen analysis
tool pack
and solver add-in and click on ok now
that basically should add more options
to your excel so if you click on data
so here you see data analysis and solver
and this is what we would want to use to
get our descriptive statistics for these
three columns so for example let's say
temperature
or you can even give the names later
once you get your descriptive statistics
so for example let's go for data
analysis
and here it says what are you interested
in there is a two factor with
replication you have correlation
covariance descriptive statistics you
have histogram so let's click on
descriptive statistics click on ok
now this one basically asks your input
range so while your cursor is blinking
here
also it is said
grouped by so let's give it a range so
for example i will say say temperature
now if i do this and i have selected the
heading just look at that and now you
need an output range so let's just
select this
and then you can have your cursor
blinking here
let's select save fields here
and this is where i would want the
output now it also said what options do
you want so it has output range we can
then select summary statistics
confidence level so i will say summary
statistics is what i'm interested in say
okay and this says input input range
contains non-numeric data now why is
that because we chose temperature the
heading also so click on ok and here we
will alter the range
so this one
is our range should be
only
the values numeric values on which we
would want the descriptive statistics we
have output range already selected we
have summary statistics and now you can
click on ok
and that basically gives your
descriptive statistics for temperature
so here i could basically
given a value for this so i can say
temperature
and that's my descriptive statistics for
temperature might be i can just do some
formatting
and
that's it so that gives me descriptive
statistics for the values here
now similarly we can do it for price of
ice cream
so what we need is
we need to basically
go for data
data analysis
descriptive statistics say okay
now you need to give a range so here i
will
change my range to these values output
range is already selected
now we are interested in summary
statistics click on ok
and this says output range will
overwrite existing data press ok to
overwrite data in range
i will say cancel now that's not what we
want to do we need to give a new range
so let's select our new range which is
here
and now click on ok
so now we get the values which is for
your price of ice cream so again we can
basically
select this and say price of ice cream
and we got our descriptive statistics
for price of ice cream and like we did
earlier i can select this
i can basically do a merge and center
and that gives me descriptive statistics
for price of ice cream so we could also
basically change this
now i can go into data and i can go into
data analysis
descriptive statistics so we know that
we had selected this b2 to b8
and this one which is h6 to h19 we would
want to shift it
might be two columns up so might be i
can just say h5
and i can manually change it to h17
and let's say okay
and
we will basically get this and i can get
rid of this
so i can have it in the same range
so similarly so this one will have to be
renamed and i can basically say price of
ice cream
and that's basically my descriptive
statistics for my price of ice cream
and similarly we can do it for the third
column which is units sold
so we would want to have this now let's
see we can click on data we can click on
data analysis descriptive statistics
so we need to give the range correctly
so this time our range changes to units
sold
now we can also say labels in first row
okay if
we were selecting the heading so let's
do it in this way so in my range
in my range
let me empty this
i can basically select this which we
know
has non-numeric data in the first row
say for example i'll say labels in first
row i'm interested in summary statistics
and this range will now have to be
changed from
h
to basically something like
j
so let's say j
and let's select these values so that
should take care of things and now you
see you have your units sold you did not
have to manually rename it
and you have basically got the
descriptive statistics so this is how
you can simply perform analysis
using data analysis here
you can basically get your descriptive
statistics for your columns and then you
can do whatever needed formatting you
need
to basically make your data look
in a
good way now let's look at one more
example of data analysis where we may
want to look at the frequency of values
or frequency of values occurring in a
range of values so for example if you
have been given temperatures
you have been given some pins where you
would want to un identify how many
values fall into the range of 0 to 20
20 to 30 30 to 40 40 to 50 and the
easiest way to do that would be creating
histogram now histogram is usually used
for data analysis where you would want
to look at different variables or say
features for example temperature is one
such feature might be there might be one
more variable or feature such as sale of
ice cream and you would want to see
if
the increase or decrease in temperature
affects the increase or decrease in
sale of ice cream might be a sale of ice
cream is a is a response based on
temperature so it depends so sometimes
you may want to find a relationship
between two variables
whether they are positively or
negatively related or you would want to
do different kind of analysis and in
certain cases we may want to
first do analysis on one single variable
look at the frequency of values might be
also look at the defects and for which
we can use something like pareto chart
so we can go for histogram and that
basically gives us the frequency of
values now how do we do that so we have
already added the
add-in which is data analysis earlier so
we can just use the same thing again
here we would want to create a histogram
so let's say okay now i have already
selected input range so if you see here
my input range is temperature which is
also with the headings
and i have bin range which is basically
the range of values so for example i can
select this and that's my pin range i am
selecting
or the option labels because i am using
the first
row which has the heading such as
temperature and bins now we need to give
an output range so for example let's say
i would want my data here
and that becomes my output range so you
can have a sorted histogram or basically
a pareto chart
so if that's what you're interested in
looking at the frequencies for your
different ranges and here i'm also
selecting chart output because i would
want to have a visual histogram which
gives us the frequency and it's as
simple as this just click on ok and now
you get your bins
so it basically tells you frequency of
values which is
basically 20 but that does not mean it
is only talking about the value is 20 it
is basically talking as a range of 0 to
20
so we have 0 to 20 that is 2 so we can
basically say there is 120 here with the
20 being the maximum value and then
there is one more 20 so that's your 0 to
20
then you have 20 to 30 which shows three
values so might be in that case i can
say 26
is one thing then i can say 30
that's the second one
and then basically i can look at 22
so
basically this one does not select 20 as
the lower range but it basically selects
30 as the higher range so i do see 20 to
30 there are three entries similarly we
can see values for 40 and 50 and since
we have selected parito or sorted
histogram that shows in a descending
order what is the highest frequency of
values within a particular range
so that shows me highest frequency is
five and then you have three and three
and then two so this is how we can
create a histogram and we can perform
analysis on a single variable
now
as discussed earlier as i said sometimes
we may
be interested in finding out the
correlation between different variables
such as say here we have temperature
price of ice cream and units sold and we
may want to
find out the correlation between one
variable to another variable or we would
want to find out the relationship
between variables
are they linearly related are they
positively related negatively related
and so on and for that we can use the
correlation
of your data analysis add-in so for
example you want to find out correlation
of temperature and units sold and what
we can do is we can find out that using
a formula so for example if i search for
something like
co
relation
and let's search so there is a function
called correlation which we can use and
we can use this to calculate the
correlation of temperature and units
sold so for example let's select this
and that's the function so it says give
me an first array and a second array so
we are interested in finding out
correlation of temperature and units
sold so let's select
the range of values for temperature and
then i am interested in finding out the
correlation of temperature in units sold
so let's select this
and that basically gives me a range of
values it gives me the correlation value
which is 0.2859
say okay and that's your value
so similarly we can do it for
temperature and price ice cream so let's
go for
correlation
so that's the function we are interested
in you need to give a range of value so
here we are interested in temperature
and price of ice cream so let's select
temperature
and then the second array or list of
values is price of ice cream let's
select that
let's close our bracket
and here we have the correlation value
of temperature and the price of ice
cream similarly you may be interested in
finding out temperature and units sold
like what we have done earlier
so we can do the same thing based on
function so this is same as
correlation of temperature in units sold
so i can get rid of this one now how do
i do it using the data analysis add in
so for that what we need is we need to
go into data we need to click on data
analysis and here you have the option
called correlation let's select this now
that basically needs an input range so
we need the range now i might be
interested in finding out the
correlation between temperature and
price of ice cream and units sold so
i've selected all the columns here
we will say grouped by columns obviously
we need to select labels in first row
because that is basically taking care of
the first row is heading now output
range you can just give one simple cell
and that's where your data will start
from or you can give a new workbook so
click on ok
and that basically gives you
that basically gives your
correlation of your different variables
and what are the values and we can check
these values
based on the values what we have here so
we have basically
temperature
and price of ice cream
and that basically shows me
0.96149
you have temperature in units sold so
you have 0.2859
now you can also look at units sold and
say for example price of ice cream
you can look at
these particular values so if i would be
interested in finding out
what is the relationship between these
variables i can easily find using
correlation so i could be
basically writing in a formula here and
selecting what are the cells so here we
were selecting a2
and c
here we were selecting a and b now might
be i'm interested in price of ice cream
and units sold and if that's what i'm
interested in then i will give a range
of b2 to b8 c2 to c8 and similarly you
can get your analysis or correlation
values
so it's very simple in excel and you can
use either the data analysis tab
and
get your correlation or you can use
formulas and do that
now one more important part of data
analysis is doing your sampling now
sampling could be periodic sampling or
random sampling so sometimes you may
want to look at a variable and you may
want to
get some values based on periodic data
that means
might be i'm interested in the range of
values i'm interested in seeing a sample
of values for
a particular period which could be
basically
a range of values or you could just do a
random sampling so for example if i go
for periodic sampling so out of these
values which i see here might be i want
to see
say periodic sampling that is a
frequency of two values how many times
we have these values occurring here or i
would go for random sampling so
basically randomly i would want to pick
up
say three temperature values now how do
i do it so for example here i have seven
values now if i go
for periodic sampling
the sample
or periodic sample value which i need to
give has to be lesser than the total
input values
so for example we can do this let's go
in here
and let's go for data analysis so we can
go for sampling here click on ok and
that needs a range of values so we will
select a2 to a8 now i could have
selected all the values for this one
temperature and in that case i can give
labels which is going to take care of
the first
row
now here we can go for
number of samples which you are
interested in or giving a period so
let's go for period and say for example
i have seven values so what if i select
five
so for example if i say five that means
i could just get
one value so basically when i'm saying 5
out of 7 so that's just giving me out of
5 i want
one value so i can then just give an
output range so here
i can basically select this cell i'll
say okay and now you see
it just shows me
one value
so out of the first range that is i have
said five it has given me the fifth
value that's your periodic sampling so
for example we want more values so let's
reduce this period
to might be 2 which basically gives me
every second value so i can basically
say
for example 2 and say ok
and then
say okay so that shows me
26
then you have 35
then you have 40 and then well this one
does not have any more values so that's
your periodic sampling now if you go for
random sampling that's basically
randomly picking up values and you can
choose how many values you want so go
for data analysis go for sampling i'll
go for number of samples how many you
want so for example out of seven values
randomly i want three values
and i can just give this say okay
and then
we will do a cancel because we need to
change that range so let's select this
and say okay and that gives me random
three values from this
values of temperature so we can use
excel to do a simple sampling and we can
choose whether we would want to go for
periodic sampling or
random sampling let's continue learning
excel and how excel can be used for data
analysis now we have seen
sampling histogram correlation
descriptive stats and now also let's
look at regression now what is
regression so when you talk about
statistical modeling regression analysis
is used to estimate the relationship
between
two or more variables and basically we
would want to look at
two or more variables
and
basically a relationship of those
variables with the response or the
target right so for example if we look
at our data here we have temperature we
have price of ice cream and then we have
units sold and we can go ahead and make
predictions so for example when you look
at regression here you see something
like this which is regression statistics
you have anova
you have different plots which we have
here which is x variable
x variable 2 and then you have normal
probability plot now we have already
seen how you can
have your add-in that is data analysis
which helps you in doing different kind
of data analysis here right now how do
we do this so we have our variables here
which is temperature price of ice cream
units sold and when we talk about
regression we need to understand which
one of these are
independent variables which one of these
are dependent variables right so when
you talk about your x
that's your independent variable or we
can say predictor or explanatory so when
you talk about your independent
variables or as we say predictors
or explanatory variables
these are the factors that
might influence the dependent variable
and when you talk about dependent
variable that's your response or target
that's the main factor you're trying to
understand or predict so we can plot a
scatter plot to see relationship between
variables
if they are linearly related are they
positively related negatively related
and so on we can also
get values such as r square which is
coefficient of determination
regression line and then
analyze the relationship between
variables so
here is one of the links of one of my
other videos where we are
learning on machine learning and also on
regression but that's programmatically
and using a processing framework such as
spark
now here let's see how do we do this in
excel so basically we would want to use
our variables which is temperature price
of ice cream units sold and then get
these plots so what we can do is for
example i can get rid of this
and might be i can just say
no borders
and
when it comes to these plots
we can have them generated again that's
not a big deal
using your data analysis
add-in tool
so we have been given variables here now
as i said when we talk about your
regression analysis we need to
understand whether we have one variable
or we have
multiple variables right so you might
have heard of univariate analysis
bivariate analysis and so on well
here we are focusing more on using excel
to do our regression analysis so i'll
not go deeper into regression topics but
certain things
as basics should be known that when we
talk about regression analysis
what does it do it helps you understand
how the dependent variable changes
when one
or more independent variables vary and
it basically allows us to mathematically
determine
which of those variables really has an
impact
so technically when we talk about
regression analysis model that is based
on the sum of squares which is basically
a mathematical way to find the
dispersion of data points so
mainly the goal
of the model is to get the smallest
possible sum of squares and draw a line
that comes closest to the data so that's
what we mean by our regression line or
basically looking at the points and
seeing if the points fall on a
regression line if there are residuals
that is points which do not fall on the
regression line and in terms of
statistics
when we talk about
statistics we differentiate between a
simple and multiple linear regression so
you have something called a simple
linear regression
models
which basically gives you the
relationship between dependent variable
and one independent variable using a
linear function and if you use two or
more variables that is explanatory
variables to predict the dependent
variable we are actually dealing with
multiple linear regression so if the
dependent variable is modeled as a
non-linear function
because the data relationships do not
follow a straight line
we have to use non-linear regression
now what we will do is we will see how
we can work on this so here we have some
variables and if we look at this
might be based on temperature price of
ice cream we would want to find out how
many units were sold now what we can do
is we can basically
start looking in by creating a simple
scatter plot which is quite easy in
excel so if you have been given
variables what you can do is you can
click on insert
you can then choose the kind of plots
which you want and here you have insert
scatter plot so we can choose this and
you can choose the first option so that
gives you a blank layout and what you
can do is now you need to select data so
for example let's click on select data
and then you can say add so what we
would want is we can give a name so we
want x values and we want our y values
right so when you talk about y that's
your dependent variable or your response
or target so that is in our case units
sold and x values are one
set of features or variables or multiple
variables so here i can click on this
series x values and then i can
select this
now in y values what i can do is i can
select these
and then i can just say okay
so that shows me that it would be giving
me a regression scatter plot now let's
say okay
and we have some points plotted here now
if you would want to see the impact of
one individual variable such as
temperature or price of ice cream you
could as well do that now what you can
also do is you can add more meaning to
this
by giving in a title or you can also go
into quick layout and you have various
options here so you see it gives you
what is the access title what is the
series and i would prefer to use here
something like this one so that gives
you your regression line that also gives
you your r square and that gives you
your y and x that is your coefficients
so let's select this one and then we
have some values which we can use to
compare this also shows me the
regression line and you can keep this
for reference if you would want you can
change
the chart title to something else say
scatter plot
of
dependent
uh
independent
variables and you can give any name
which has more meaning
and
we can get rid of this one so we have
series and we can say what are these
points if you would want to add in
legend if you would want to do that or i
can just get rid of this
and
i will keep these values here which we
will
see when we do a data analysis we can
always
compare these values so here i have
created a simple scatter plot
and then i can look at dependent wise
independent variables
or i could have selected one particular
variable so this is just for reference
now we can add more details we can say
what is my x-axis what is my y-axis
so basically you can here
say for example just say y
and might be here i will say
x
and we can rename that later
now
how do we perform data analysis or get
into regression
right now what we would want to do is
we would want to get
or we would want to do the regression
analysis to demonstrate the relationship
between
dependent and independent variables
so normally when you talk about your
linear regression equation you might
have known about it so it is basically y
when you say y
equals
you can say
bx plus a
plus c
and this would be normally the
mathematical equation for a linear
regression where
x
is your independent variable
y
is your dependent variable
your
a is the y-intercept
which is expected
mean value of y
when all x variables are equal to zero
so basically on a regression graph
that's the point where line crosses the
y axis and that's your intercept
when you talk about b that's basically
your slope of regression line which is
the rate of change for y as x changes
and then you also have
your constant right so that's your uh
sorry that's basically your random error
term right which is basically
the difference
between the actual value of dependent
variable and its predicted value so your
linear equation
always has an error term because in real
life predictors are obviously never
perfectly precise
right now what we can do is we can also
reduce this
equation to
y is b x
plus a
and that's the equation of a line we can
look into this and the linear equation
can be understood mathematically in this
way now how do we do it in excel so what
we can simply do is
[Music]
here let
me
yeah
so
we need to get into data and then here
we have our data analysis add in you can
click on this one and from these
different options you can choose
regression so that's what we would want
to do now we'll say okay now here you
need to give your input y range so as i
said you will have to select
the dependent and independent variables
right so we would want to do some
regression analysis here and here we
have your x and y
so y being your target
that's basically your units sold so we
can select this along with the labels
when it comes to x either you can select
one variable or multiple variables so i
will select temperature price of ice
cream
and then since we have chosen the
headings we will go for labels
right
now we can always look at the confidence
level we can change that
so you can say whether you want it in a
new worksheet or you can just say output
range and i will probably
just click here and select one of the
cell here
now we can also choose the other options
which we would want to see as a part of
this regression analysis
so basically we have selected input y
range which is your dependent variable
you have selected x range which is your
independent variable and if we are
building a multi-regression model then
we
have chosen temperature and price of ice
cream both
now we can choose the labels which we
have done we can choose your output
range which is basically on this sheet
and then we can select the residuals
so that basically gives you your
residuals now we can also get your line
fit plots which you were seeing earlier
you can also go for your normal
probability plots and then basically
just say okay
and
let's say okay
and that basically gives you
your regression analysis output
so we
basically have your summary output
we also have anova
we have
our serial output that's from the
previous one
and basically we can get rid of this
that's not required
i can get rid of this one
yeah so now we have our regression
statistics we also have our plots so we
can basically look into these
so we have our normal
let's get rid of these
let's get rid of this let's get rid of
this
and then what we can do is
since we had some existing data it has
overwritten so let me get rid of this
and i'll repeat this step again
and
uh let's say no water yeah
so now what we want to do is we want to
do a reaction analysis
so we go get into data we get into data
analysis we choose regression
we have already chosen our y range which
is column c
x range is multiple variables we have
gone for labels
output range which we would want to
select a particular cell
so let me select this
i am going for residuals line fit plots
normal probability plots and say okay
so now
we have our plots
we can just separate them to have a
better understanding
yeah and that basically shows you the
variables so here it shows me units sold
and then what are the predicted units
sold and here the variable is
temperature
here the variable is price of ice cream
right so that's your one variable and
second variable and then you also have
your normal probability plot
now to interpret this
or to understand what we have here where
we look at your
summary output so it is good to
understand what excel is helping us out
so basically when we do a regression in
excel it is performing all the
calculations automatically the
interpretation is something which we
need to understand so basically we are
looking at
multiple r value here
and we can
let's also fine tune this one
here
we have our values here and if you see
we have our r square now
we can then basically look at
our multiple r so what is your multiple
r that's your correlation coefficient
which basically measures the strength of
linear relationship
between two variables so
[Music]
this can be any value between your when
you talk about your correlation
coefficient
it can be any value between minus one
and one and its absolute value indicates
the relationship strength
so
the larger the absolute value the
stronger the relationship so one
basically means a strong positive
relationship minus 1 means a strong
negative relationship and 0 means no
relationship at all
now when you are looking at r square
that is the coefficient of determination
which is used as an indicator of the
goodness of the fit
so it basically shows how many points
fall on the regression line so your r
square value is basically calculated
from the total sum of squares
when we say precisely it is the sum of
squared deviations of the original data
from the mean
now
when we talk about
looking at the value of your r square
so it is basically we can be seeing
uh that this is
0.450788
that's the value which i'm talking about
so it basically means
45 of our values fit the regression
analysis model
so in other words
45 percent of dependent variables that
is your y values are explained by the
independent variables that is your x
values
so normally if you have r squared value
higher then that is considered as a good
fit
and here we have considered multiple
variables
now when you talk about your adjusted r
square it is the r square adjusted for
the number of independent variables in
the model
so
you would want to use this value instead
of r square for multiple regression
analysis
such as in our case
now you also have standard error so
that's basically
goodness of fit measure that basically
shows the precision of your regression
analysis so the smaller the value the
more certain you can be about your
regression equation
so
when when we talk about your r square
that represents the percentage of
dependent variables variance
that is explained by the model and
standard error is basically an absolute
measure that shows the average
distance that the data points fall from
the regression line so you will have to
look back into regression
statistics
terminologies to basically understand
more of this and if you're already from
data science background that
then you already know what i'm talking
about we are just seeing how excel
easily helps us in doing these things
now
we can also look at observations here
which is basically the number of
observations in our model which is 7.
now when we talk about regression
analysis and if we look at analysis of
variance that is your anova values here
so we basically see df you have ss
ms f and significance f
now to understand these
so basically what we are doing is or
what excel is doing is it splits the sum
of squares into individual components
that give information about the levels
of variability within your regression
model so when you talk about your df
that's basically the number of degrees
of freedom associated with the source of
variance you have sum of squares that is
your ss
so smaller the residual ss compared with
the total ss
the better your model fits the data
right now when you talk about ms that's
your mean square you have f is basically
the f statistic
or you can say
f test for the null
hypothesis basically it is used to
test the overall significance of the
model and then you finally have your
significance f
which is the p value of f so
when we when we usually talk about
seeing simple linear regression the in
anova part is uh
not
really used or it's rarely used
right but when we look at the
significance f value that gives an idea
of how reliably
or statistically significant our results
are so if significance f is less than
0.05
that's five percent our model is okay if
it is greater than point zero five
we will have to better choose another
independent variables
right now we can also look at the output
of coefficients and that's what we would
want to look at
so you basically have your intercept
here so when you talk about your
intercept temperature price of ice cream
so we know we are looking at our
variables and then we are also look at
looking at our
intercept which basically gives you
more details on your coefficients
so the the main important thing when we
talk about regression analysis
is basically your coefficients it
basically enables you to build a linear
regression equation
uh in the form of y equals bx plus a
which i explained earlier
and then basically we can understand our
regression analysis
output better now when we look at the
residual output which we are seeing here
so that gives you your observations how
many observations we have
it shows what is the predicted units
sold and then it also gives you your
residuals
so we can compare the estimated and
actual number of sold umbrellas based on
the observation so we have 11.209
here and if you compare that's basically
12
the second one is 15 and here it is 13.5
you have and similarly you can compare
all the values of actual units sold and
what our regression has predicted
so basically what we can do is we can
compare these
and
we will see if there is any difference
or no right
so
obviously there will be or there would
be some difference because independent
variables are never
perfect predictors of your dependent
variables
and the residuals
basically help us in understanding how
far the actual values are from the
predicted values
so that's what we see here in the
residual section
so for example when we look at this one
which is
11.209 and the actual is 12 we see what
is the residual and how far
is the predicted value from the actual
value
so
similarly we can also look at the
percentile values so that gives you your
probability output and this is what we
have in our graphs
so we have basically our variables
we are looking at our variables and also
the units sold and the relationship
between them we can basically
uh add in more details to this
particular plot and you also have normal
probability plot which is basically
getting
your values from your
probability output here so this is how
you can perform a simple regression
analysis and now what you can do is you
can
as i said you can basically be looking
at your scatter plot you can be looking
at your y and x and your r square values
right but remember what are the
variables which you are selecting
and then you can compare these
with basically the values what you see
here
so remember here i've chosen
my both set of variables
and you can choose
one variable and then basically see what
is its impact on the response or on the
target
so
it's pretty simple here you can
add more details to your scatter plot or
the plots what we have created
or
some people prefer to do it using
formulas so
basically we have some statistical
functions that it can help you do linear
regression analysis such as
you have
linus you have slope you have intercept
you have correlation and so on so
basically
you can use these particular functions
and what you will have to do is
you will have to
basically go in for a function if that's
what you would want to do and then you
can search for functions
and say for example i'll just say nest
and say go and here i have my function
so if i would want to really use this
one i can do that
what i will have to do is then select
the variable so if you just say okay and
that basically says your known y's known
x your constants your stats and
basically you can use the formula also
but we are not covering that here might
be in the later videos we can do that so
just try out and perform some regression
analysis
and try to look at your different
variables and try to interpret that so
that basically gives you
an easier way of performing regression
analysis
using your data analysis add-in in excel
now with that we have come to an end of
this session on who is a business
analyst and business analysis with excel
if you have any queries regarding any of
the topics covered in this session or if
you require the resources that we used
in this session then do let us know in
the comment section below and our team
of experts will be more than happy to
resolve all your queries at the earliest
until next time thank you stay safe and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you